is like terrified of like male nipples
no it's because you know when you don't
want to stare at something but then you
just end up looking it could continue
feel like it's staring into my soul and
i just feel uncomfortable in other words
you don't stare at the nipple the nipple
stares you back
hello my fellow sigma males and welcome
to trash taste i'm with my usual fellow
sigma males connor and joey hello and we
are with our mom maelyn maker of the
boys
she birthed us from her mind vagina
we were just discussing today and we
were like should we just bring melanie
back on yeah just start
how many episodes has it been since
you're on you're on like episode
six or something or episode seven or
something you're like
you're the only person who's been on
trash taste that has not signed a
shikishi um so we've got to change that
now
she signs our checks
she gives us a signature every month
yeah we thought we'd uh we thought we'd
uh mix things up this episode and i
guess uh bring on our manager and i
guess get a female perspective on things
right
how does female sound derogatory when
you say it doesn't it
people who say female it's not like
females
would you do you like it when someone
refers to you as a female
i i'm indifferent oh okay
i've had i've had people who've been
like you hate being called a male
no but i've had i've had oh that male 1
i've had a i've had friends who've been
like oh female sounds so like in selly
like devorah
yeah i don't think the word itself if
you're just like yo female
how's it going
that's offensive hello my fellow females
like little females
this is another night i watched a lot of
anime and not anime animal videos on
youtube so like oh this
female badger so i'm like yeah
although
in like child like uh nature shows i
think they say girls and boys don't they
the girl badger yeah like the girl
badger oh yeah i i think
like
i think for like newborns yeah right and
then and then like and then i guess the
when when they reach of age i don't even
know what that is yeah like well they're
an adult they're just male and females
but i i've never thought about this
deeply well because boy and girl kind of
sounds more like we're getting really
into it now yeah yeah
whereas like you're not gonna like point
to a baby and go that female over there
you would save that baby
but but like if you want to if you want
to specify which baby
you would say the girl baby
or the girl
yeah that little girl right you don't
say that little female
what are we talking about i don't i
don't know
i don't even know what we're talking
about after dinner you guys are full and
it's just like
don't date this
don't tell them when we record yeah i
don't want to know
i don't want them to know our eating
habits and our recording habits jesus
sitting up there what's the strangest
thing you've seen one of us do
no pressure just wondering it's just
let's keep let's go because i feel
maylene's perspective of weird is very
different to the average female
the hard f jesus [ __ ] this is female oh
my gosh what a terrible start
do you know do you have something in
mind or do you not want to say it okay
okay okay well
the most recent stuff is the stuff that
comes to mind i haven't been watching
you guys record that much so i'm like
upstairs yeah recently uh well it
doesn't have to be on camera oh okay
yeah because i will say like definitely
recording trash taste uh has made me
more self-conscious and also hanging out
with maelyn has made me look
self-conscious as well
no no no sometimes i'm just sometimes
i'll just do something subconsciously
like for example i'll be sitting there
and i'll like have my hand in my sock
you know oh yeah yeah yeah which just
just happened like half an hour ago and
she was like i wouldn't say let's see
it's not weird what is cute when sydney
calls you little baby man
[Laughter]
like it was thanksgiving and then sydney
was like oh my sydney goes oh it's my
little baby and then guard i thought
garnet's like this you know it is like
when your mom is like oh my
little boy is doing well
like
[Laughter]
and i'm just like whoa
sydney's god she is she is my [ __ ]
mom isn't she yeah right she's just like
trying to [ __ ] embarrass me right now
jesus
no because because like i feel like
sydney sydney started saying that just
like to piss me off and then like you
you know
no no no no no
because like you know when you know when
it's like you know when you're in like a
group of friends
right and then you say something
ironically yeah and then oh then you
just you start saying something
ironically and then you keep doing it
and then it becomes unironic right
little baby man
no because that that came that came from
just a random [ __ ] video like because
i i remember when joey used to [ __ ]
dab everywhere i'm just like joey can
you stop [ __ ] dabbing everywhere yeah
and then i started doing it and i'm just
like i [ __ ] hate it you don't have to
dab all the time yeah because i made it
uh uh my life mission i think it was
like 2016 2017 i i told myself at the
beginning of that year i'm like i'm
gonna do a social experiment every photo
i upload of myself that year i need to
be dabbing and i'm just gonna see if i
can like fulfill that just to see how
far i can i did it no way yeah all every
single photo every photo of me of in
2017 i'm dabbing why would why would you
do that because it's hilarious
because seeing the comments i'm not
seeing because because all of the angry
comments of people being like why are
you doing this it was just funny to me
yeah but then when at which point did it
stop becoming ironic you just ended up
doing it because that definitely did
reach that point yeah i think after
maybe the second time i did it
[Laughter]
i was like oh it's kind of it's kind of
fun i did think there was a year that
you did dabble and that was probably the
year then yeah that was probably the
year we met actually
what an awful impression what an awful
first impression but like i feel you're
very like heavily influenced by the
people around you in that sense because
like recently in that you know in that
same sense right like you started
dabbing
on ironically after i kept doing it
no but then like you know like on this
[ __ ] podcast right like you know i'm
very known to saying i [ __ ] with this
and then god started saying it
chronically as well what can i say if
you hang out with your homies enough huh
you also say a hundred percent
100 percent sometimes it echoes in my
head like after recording i go home walk
into the train 100
if one of us is doing something the
other is just programming like i don't
think god does stuff that rubs off on
you i feel like it's it's
only you rubbing off on the dog
wow
no no no you just hang out with your
hobbies enough and you just i guess you
just start to mirror each other yeah i
don't know i hang out with you a lot but
i still sip like a normal human being i
mean that's just me yeah i'm
not that sure
i i don't know why i sip like that it's
just i just it's just i think it's the
sippy cups that i just can't sit like a
normal human being i don't [ __ ] know
yeah it's like you feel like a baby i
feel like yeah sometimes drinking
i'm gonna find the original video that's
based on but uh one thing i do want to
talk about maylin is uh the viewers
don't know this but
you are like
you are like one of the most prolific
google reviewers in japan oh yeah you
are right it used to be
three or four years
i just started were you like what was
the highest rank of food reviews
or something like top 5 or something wow
and it goes it gives you a different
score every month so i didn't even know
you had scores i didn't right yeah did i
pay you
no did you just do it for like the
clowns
no no she she does it for the prestige i
do for the badges
like it just says oh you're a novice or
novice she literally does for the xbox
achievements
so you literally play pokemon go just in
real life yeah
with like restaurants and stuff yeah
yeah yeah to be fair whenever
mainlanders recommend me a restaurant
it's normally very it's usually pretty
good yeah if i've eaten there oh yeah
i'll go there and i'll feel like wow
this is amazing i mean it was like yeah
i'll give it a three out of five and i'm
like what
yeah every time we go to we can't go to
a restaurant with maelyn anymore and
have her enjoy her meal because every
time we're there i can see the cogs
turning you just don't ask me just don't
look at me while i'm eating
i can't help it it's like yeah yeah
super fascinating watching your thought
process as you as you eat this food i
really enjoy food but i do just eat it
very fast
you do like you're someone who eats food
so fast that i don't know how you can
enjoy it i okay so i've i've one
do you have weekday eating mode and
weekend eating mode
uh
but also when i think when i think when
i think i'm eating this too fast and
then i slow down like my chewing or
whatever i'm like it doesn't really
taste any better
it just makes you feel full
does it yeah the slower you eat the
slower you eat the more food you get
yeah
it's like because because it's because
it takes a certain amount of time for
your stomach to process it and for a
signal to get sent to your brain that
says hi i'm full so if you actually eat
slower then it's just a much more
natural way to eat less because then
it'll you'll get full much faster i
think if i'm not like dining with people
i don't really like to take it slow
i like to just eat it and get on with
what i'm doing yeah if you're at like a
fancy restaurant
oh my god
you have to try these bananas they're
dashing slowly this swerves the wine
oh my gosh you know i mean it's one bite
i mean i feel like that's part of the
experience like i think i think part of
the experience of enjoying food with me
is not just the food it's like like
social aspect it's the social aspect and
also the drink as well like having
getting a pair getting the food paired
with like the perfect drink actually
like really enhances the experience
right i feel like i feel like just food
tastes so much worse when you're eating
it alone
do you think so i actually agree with
you yeah
like i like like i don't think so we're
just talking
if it's like abc when i have good food i
feel so sad when no one else is around
to appreciate the good food as well i'm
like this is good you take a picture of
you
that's whenever we got to eat i'm like
mailing it's good right that means like
no but i'm like i'm loving it i'm like
this is great sometimes i'm just like
i'm gonna ask melin because i am really
enjoying the meal right now and i'm
afraid that she's just gonna dash my
dreams yeah we had the we had like a
she's like just like that reviewer that
you don't want to hear the opinion of
like
i don't care people dislike my favorite
shows but when i go to like when we at
the old studio yeah we had like the
stone bay pizza place yeah that was
really good yeah we loved it and it was
like it was like five 4.5 or something
it was really hard that was fantastic on
google reviews and we took melina milne
was like no
i can't no it's just because i don't
like pizza to begin with
what what what
contender for the shittiest take of the
year that's pretty bad that's pretty bad
why wait wait there's no type of pizza
you like
there is a specific pizza one that's
made in san francisco oh my god oh for
[ __ ]
oh yes
and the entire world grows
pizza
but even though i could only eat like
one pizza a year i don't i don't really
like it
yeah i've
needs to be in san francisco i have
never felt all the italians just [ __ ]
died yeah
it's healing guys
what the [ __ ] was that there's better
foods to eat than pizza i think i just
think i just thought
every human on earth enjoyed pizza i
just thought it was a mutual love yeah i
just thought it was there it was just
like i'm i'm pretty sure it's like a
test for like how to determine if you're
an alien or a human right because
because like if they don't love pizza
then they're probably an alien right
because no human doesn't love pizza what
do you like about pizza
do you like cheese i think it depends
it's all about timing for pizza when
they get it out and how long they're
cooking if it's crispy soggy
so many places get it wrong
you know
how would you write how would you write
dominoes
i wouldn't rate it like it's it's like
it's like not even worth it's like not
worth eating okay there's sometimes
there's some moments where you're
watching a movie or something during a
long break and you want to eat something
greasy then pizza the dominoes i'll eat
dominoes right right it's not like
freaking out
it's not like amazing okay what is like
the best fast food then in your opinion
if you say in and out i swear to god i
like in and out though i really like it
but yeah but knowing knowing how much
she loves san francisco she's never had
i actually really like mcdonald's yeah
me too me too but like american
mcdonald's japanese mcdonald's japanese
makeup it's all the same no it's not no
american mcdonald's makes me had
american hamburgers
i would no
american mcdonald's mcdonald's
i just get the nugs nugs are like
universally just the same everywhere
actually
yeah yeah yeah i mean nugs nugs are
great the fries are great i think
mcdonald's fries are the best i don't
like the major change but if they're
like soggy it's like well that's
actually they're good when they're soggy
and cold and they've kind of been like
sweating a bit why is this what is this
come on you're joking
what's this
google food reviewer
this is the house this is the hardcore
expert when you go on google how to lose
your credibility in like five minutes
like this the google review thing it
doesn't really mean much it just means i
contribute a lot how did that start i'm
so curious about how you just who how
are you literally the only person i know
who does this i think it was an
obsession because like there would be
new restaurants that pop up and then i'd
be the first one
out of everyone in the neighborhood i
mean that is true tokyo like switches
out restaurants like crazy yeah yeah
yeah fast like restaurants pop up and go
yeah yeah it was really cool whenever i
log into my google maps account be like
wow
you've got a million point 1.2 million
views on your photo i'm like whoa
how it feels to be a youtuber
nobody comments they just look at it
which i like like oh yeah they saw it
it's just the youtube video with the
comments i went to kfc one time and
uploaded a picture of my friend eating a
kfc yeah and for some reason google made
the front picture
it was like you click on this kfc it's a
pretty popular kfc and it was just him
sitting there eating a kfc not not a
flattering photo why did you upload that
because i wanted to see how it works
that's hilarious i wanted to see how it
worked and i found out afterwards you
can't take down google photos no you
can't and he was furious
why did you put it you can
google maps and it's like your picture
is popular and i'm like what the [ __ ]
it's my name
but uh yeah sorry so i mean
so you start reviewing things yeah yeah
when did you get addicted was it like
immediately or like
like after two months i started eating
at more places so do you like go out on
purpose to look for new places or do you
kind of just like wait till when you
place pops up
well i get tired of
eating the same food a lot yeah so
when my husband asked me where do you
want to eat i'll be like can we go
somewhere new i just want like
that stimulation that like excitement i
hate it because i never used to be like
that and then i moved to japan and then
i'm just like i want to eat something
different every day so many japan has
the most for example michelin
restaurants in the world and you don't
even have to eat at a michelin-starred
restaurant everything
if you're a peasant
do you rate the michelin star
restaurants because i know you've been
to it i do i do you do yeah okay but
it's also kind of weird if you go there
often and then the chef knows you rated
them so
i don't they probably they probably
think you're one of like one of the
reviewers at this point one restaurant
that i i really liked yeah and then i
just don't review it because i don't
want them to know my thoughts
what makes a good and a bad reviewer
uh a bad viewer is just like oh this
place was this place sucked or it was
too expensive because i normally only
give out five stars and i don't review
restaurants i don't like uh yeah that's
the problem i think a lot of people only
review restaurants they hate or some
restaurants they really like yeah right
they can't be bothered to formulate a
middle ground yeah when i look at a
place and then i see maybe there's only
three ratings and then i look at the
three reviewers and this person only has
two reviews this person has 40. i look
at their profile so you don't look at
just the reviews you stalk the account
of the reviewer to to
you're like you're like a jury analyzer
like because
the credibility of the jurors yeah
because for example if these two
reviewers have a streak or record of
just giving two stars why would i trust
this
i just don't think i have the effort to
like click on something because you
don't care you just uber eats everything
but also you don't even check a
restaurant before you try it the people
who normally sound like the biggest
dicks other like the local experts yeah
yeah they always have like the most
snobbish reviews
and like i i every time i read them i'm
like what the [ __ ] happened like you
made it seem like often you read google
reviews uh if i ever go to a new place i
always look at them
really
i just look at the stars and i'm like
yeah that looks good enough is that
melin's influence no i just always did
that oh okay because sometimes people
maybe like comment like the best dish
yeah
you know sometimes i don't really know
and occasionally i can't read it it's
all in kanji and then i'm like i pointed
the picture i'm like give me this one
yeah what this is it's like a menu what
this guy had
you'll do that no why
menus here that have no pictures yeah
yeah sometimes go through the picture
sometimes you just gotta put your face
also yeah i do gods and just order food
i don't know
just throw the dice what do you do in
that situation is also me ask for the
recommendation yeah whatever he says
you're like yes
i hope this is good i just get whatever
sounds nice i don't know like sometimes
sometimes you hungry joe's that [ __ ] but
joey can read yeah
i'm dumb there's some like handwritten
menus i'm just like one oh yeah
those are so hard to even like remotely
figure out what's being like said oh if
that's the case then i asked the
waitress i'm like what does that say
i actually have if you can't read it
then
sometimes like i've seen some
handwritten ones especially like really
fancy like japanese restaurants where
they're like love to use that like
traditional calligraphy style and i'm
like yeah like this just looks like
squiggles to me the ones with the hugo
audio menu
i mean like daily specials i'll always
ask but like i've seen menus that is
literally illegible where it's just so
messy and they always use like fancy
terminology that you just doesn't work
outside of that context
my favorite moment of eating in japan is
when you go to ryokan it's like 20
courses
and they just come over to you and
explain every dish and i just look at
the thing for like two minutes straight
just nodding them
see i'm actually interested in those
kinds of menus though i don't know what
they're saying to me i'm just like what
the [ __ ] you say i'm like nodding
nodding all right this is getting a
little like yeah in your head it's like
this is food this is also food this is a
food
called
i think you eat it or take like half a
bite and then tell them what is this
that i just say and then they that
that's better like if they have time but
like usually what they do is they bring
all the food out right and then they
explain it and then they just [ __ ] off
yeah you don't even have enough time
unless you're eating it as they're
explaining it right i
are you the local expert do you get that
badge as well
i'm not sure
hey like i'm just so curious like how
often do you have to eat at somewhere
new to be in the top five percent i have
no idea i haven't been top five percent
since like
2017 or that's 40. because you do quite
a lot of reviews yeah how many reviews
does it take to be in the top i have no
idea it's becoming more mainstream maybe
there's a there's a japanese guy as well
who's like trying to review every single
starbucks in japan oh yeah yeah i know
that guy and it's like ridiculous they
taste all the same that's what i
wondered
how many what can the difference be yeah
that's like going to like every
mcdonald's in japan he has to probably
order the same thing from each place
though otherwise it's not a good
comparison probably but i think they
have the seasonal venues even now yeah
now starbucks japan just released a
thing where every single prefecture has
its own frappuccino yeah oh does it yeah
that's such a japanese idea it's
actually really cool it's kind of genius
yeah they all look super super unique as
well like none of the flavors look the
same
i went to kyoto the other day and i had
like the kyoto frappuccino yeah and it
was like uh it was like macho with like
caramel and some [ __ ] i'm like wow yeah
[ __ ] it if i could only have this here
tokyo one sucks what's the tokyo it's
like coffee jelly and some [ __ ] that is
the very tokyo thing the coffee shop do
you like jelly yeah i think jelly is the
worst dessert like it is by far no have
you had nikon jelly i don't give a [ __ ]
it is bomb that shit's born why why is
it jelly is literally the dessert of
peasants what are you talking about
what are you actually told this is
incorporated on all kinds of highs
the cheapest dessert
what that's the cheapest one it's the
cheapest one
someone needs to taste she can be
delicious though it doesn't have to be
expensive basically like mattress filler
i don't want to eat it no because like
you don't just want jelly by itself
right i mean sometimes you want jelly by
itself but it's if it's like
incorporated in a dessert you don't like
it it's really [ __ ] good it's a bit
of ice i can't know i can't stand it
it's awful i love coffee what do you
like about jelly
it's just it tastes like nothing half
the time and when it does taste like
something it's like you could have made
you could have made something else
you could have made
you could have made literally anything
else with this flavor profile and it
would have been 10 times better because
it didn't feel like a floppy mess in my
mouth it's something it's just a very
large jelly
it's just a very light flavor that like
it's not too strong yeah a lot of times
it's just very light sometimes i don't
want a dessert that like punches me in
the fridge it's like like a slippery and
also
just lighter than like an ice cream is
it also the texture you don't like the
texture is a massive part of it okay but
i also find that so you don't like
gelatinous the no but i and i found that
the flavors can
be replicated in any other dessert that
is just better like what like ice cream
ice cream
ice creams you need an ice cream jelly
don't taste anything like what are you
talking about jelly you could have done
ice cream coffee you know what i mean
like that would have been usually yeah
usually you get like a vanilla ice cream
with coffee jelly like that shit's great
no no just put put just put like a porn
espresso on it
i'd rather that don't do this jelly [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's jelly
ice cream and jelly taste nothing alike
even if they have the same flavor
profile yeah it's like it's like two
totally different things
i don't know i just i i find that it's
like i just don't think you're a fan of
gelatinous things yeah no and it's also
like when they do it i'm like really
couldn't afford gelato or ice cream
really
you feel like that that's what's going
on
peasants yeah like i was like i'm like
oh okay connor's at a michelin star
restaurant they're certainly
yeah oh you have and if they gave me
jelly i'd be like wow i saw i saw what
you skimmed on the budget
jelly you know i can make i can make uh
20 liters of jelly in like 10 minutes
with like 10 bucks you know i don't want
the [ __ ]
you know how hard it would be to fill a
bathtub of ice cream that shit's going
to actually taste like nothing though
like the jelly that comes out of like
higher end restaurants actually has a
lot of flavor in my opinion it's like
fruit they'll extract the juice oh god i
hate fruit jelly so much jelly's the
best it's like fruit is the
literally the best you ruined fruit by
making it into a jelly format it's
literally no there's some fruits that
are better yeah like mekong yeah
i i would i would argue that like fruits
make better jellies than they do ice
cream
[Applause]
the texture of how it's changed by being
cooked
look look look jelly like fruit jelly is
refreshing as [ __ ] fruit ice cream is
not refreshing a lot of the times
i will take strawberry jelly over
strawberry ice cream any day
yeah what
never happened good strawberry jelly
though well strawberry jelly is normally
like the cheap the chicken
jello the the jello it's only the cheap
jelly but like so strawberry ice cream
so every ice cream is normally the cheap
the cheap ice cream i do not like
strawberry ice cream i don't oh my god
oh my god this is one of my brothers
this is more of brothers
i don't like it either
but i would i would take it over jelly
strawberry ice cream i think is just
like the worst ice cream it always
tastes like strawberries yeah banana
though hug industry banana is good but
it's not that's not the same flavor as
an actual banana why does banana lend
itself so well to everything like
everything banana flavor tastes amazing
yeah i agree with that and like
everything orange tastes so artificial
in [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i didn't say that
[Laughter]
the lollipops right americans call them
lollipops too right yeah lollipops yeah
don't don't choose the subject sorry uh
your worries taste like [ __ ]
no you're wrong you're wrong i i think
like i think the orange orange desserts
aren't better than bananas
oh come on
do you like moose by the way yeah i like
moose
sometimes
it's like it's like
do you just hate desserts connor i love
you
we found the reason [ __ ] ladies and
gentlemen
we found the reason
categorically right i have not had a
single dessert right that i'm like
ice cream would just be better than this
it's not a single dessert maybe think
ice cream is better i can find you a
dessert well like apple pie apple pie is
great it's okay but
i can i can find you something better
but like what was the thing that you
only like apple pie because it works
well with ice cream
anything that works well with ice cream
balls
do you like chocolate cakes i love
chocolate cake what kind of chocolate
like japanese chocolate cake oh i don't
think i've ever had japanese oh i got
like a volcano chocolate american
sometimes icing is too heavy you know
yeah yeah like cement like it's lighter
when you microwave it
that just sounds that's the tidbit for
the day no it's so good
why would you want it
sometimes sometimes you just don't want
something as heavy as ice just have
freeze you just have less which is a
cream just have less ice cream huh
if americans saw the hargender size in
japan i think they'd cry i i cried when
i first saw it have you seen how tiny no
to me that's the perfect size yeah i
can't have any more haagen dazs than
that but i won't lie i do wish i had the
tub just so if i really didn't have a
bad day i could chow down the two of
them like does dessert's the one meal
where i'm like really picky because it
depends on what i've eaten directly
beforehand that dictates what dessert i
order right you can't just order the
same dessert every time i don't even i
don't eat desserts yeah like like okay
like like like i i agree that ice cream
i think is the best dessert it's either
ice cream or cake right but i i can't
like if if i had if i like an empty
stomach i'd always go for ice cream or
cake but like
sometimes you just don't feel like that
after a really heavy meal sometimes
sometimes chocolate just seems way too
heavy and you just want something light
always
german soup or ice cream in some form
tiramisu i i could have like anything
and i can be half a tiramisu after to be
fair tiramisu is my favorite cake but i
can't have it after every meal i can
have everything really it's a very heavy
egg it's a heavy cake is it heavy it
doesn't feel heavy at all
like it's like to me the biggest [ __ ]
lie i hear people say is like oh you
have a second stomach for dessert i'm
like [ __ ] that shit's alive [ __ ]
you just didn't enough you just didn't
eat enough main course that's it no it's
actually it's true [ __ ] you check your
mind
the way your taste buds work is that
they get sick of one flavor so when you
introduce a new flavor it makes more
room for it no that's not just not with
me that's not the concrete but you
switch back
[Laughter]
watched a very yeah
vox video about this and apparently yeah
it's you you tell me oh my god i want to
see melanie at a buffet i can't eat as
much as me oh hi it me joey here to do
the sponsors for this episode and you'll
be happy to know that this episode of
trash days is sponsored by gentian
impact gangster impact is an open world
action rpg game available on pc android
ios and playstation 4 and 5. step into a
vast magical world now and start your
adventure on the continent of tevat
where seven kinds of elemental powers
surge you guys should know ganshin
impact by now it's taking the internet
by storm at this point but in case
you've been living under a rock and
didn't know ganshin impact has some
exciting updates for you all a new
update for version 2.1 is the floating
world under the moonlight update after
joining the resistance troops travelers
are now fighting against the shogunates
and all mysteries will unfold in the
final chapter of innozuma arkhan quest
omnipresence over mortals we have the
brand new character raiden shogun
available to paul between 1st of
september to the 21st of september the
undisputed supreme ruler of inazuma her
excellency the almighty narukami orosho
promised the people of inazuma an
unchanging eternity to last throughout
the ages but if you have a bad history
of pulling 5 stars then don't worry
there's also a brand new 4 star
available for you as well the 4 star
electro character kujo sara is here
leader of the 10-year commission's force
bold decisive and skilled in battle as
the adopted daughter of the cujo clan
she conducts herself with an official
demeanor at all times and there is
another beautiful five-star awaiting for
your hands to get ahold of i'm of course
talking about sagonomia kokomi the new
five-star hydro character the divine
priestess and supreme leader of the
wadasami island but if characters aren't
your thing then don't worry there's lots
more juicy information for you all
because two of the new inazuma islands
will open to players the wadatomi island
and the sarai island watson island is
very different from other islands in
inazuma the saganomia shrine is located
at the center of this island surrounded
by a canopy of mountains and waterfalls
meanwhile sera island is where some
disasters seem to have occurred and is
surrounded by perpetual thunderstorms
plus there are a number of exclusive
events available as well like the moon
chase festival from the 17th of
september to the 12th of october and of
course the first anniversary celebration
starting off with the passage of clouds
event which is a login bonus event that
lets players accumulate daily logins
from the 28th of september to claim up
to 10 intertwined fate along with
various other rewards so even if you're
a new player or an experienced player
against your impact has a lot to offer
to you guys so make sure to go down to
the link in the description below to
check out the game for yourself and
thank you to against nimpo for
sponsoring this episode back to the show
it's a buffet for peasants
uh las vegas has a lot of good buffets
i've heard this
i mean you'll pay like a hundred but
isn't it like mainly buffets it's all
buffets really yeah like i would i stay
because you know aki's from vegas right
so like literally every third day is a
buffet and after a while i'm just like
bruh i can we have like something else
just like a single meal i get it though
because you're just gonna sit there and
gamble all night so yeah it doesn't
matter if you like just stuff yourself
yeah you're going to feel like if you
feel like if you've been like walking
around on the strip all day yeah and you
have enough room then yeah of course
buffet's fantastic but you know if i'm
like [ __ ]
lazily sitting around in a house and
then someone sometimes argues i was like
let's go to a buffet i'm like no please
no no i can't but they have no time
limit you could be there all day kind of
actually some of them look amazing as
well i think i saw some youtube videos
of them and it's like michelin star
chefs or something yeah yeah
we've been to all of them and some of
them are [ __ ] amazing but it's also
like a buffet bus tour
no it takes you around to all the
buffets no i haven't i i i know a friend
who why would you want to have a pass
that takes you on the same day i always
wanted to go do when i started that's
like a buffet of a buffer
that's literally
no i want to that sounds horrible when i
start eating i don't want to stop until
i'm done yeah and then when i'm done i
stopped yeah yeah yeah because the worst
thing is when you are like timed for my
meal yeah and the worst thing is if you
get on the bus we're going yeah if you
start a meal and you're not totally full
but then you stop yeah you stop anyway
because you've got to leave or you want
to do something else and then you kind
of become full but not the satisfying
form yeah yeah you just like it's like
the bloated full right yeah
yeah and that's that sounds like an
awful experience yeah if you had to do
that on the same day on the buffer fun
for like college
student aged people i think when you
have firstly there is nothing
why don't why don't you just go to one
buffet then instead yeah
i wouldn't go to buffet now though but i
i did used to really like buffet i mean
i still do love buffets it's just that
there's a time and a place for it i
can't have it every day yeah i can't
have it right wait how do you rate
buffets then because there's so many
different types i can't rape a face i
didn't do google reviews back when i was
eating what about japan buffets have you
had the buffets here yeah i've had i
took you guys i think yeah only conor
carne did we we introduced
oh
it's a hot pot buffet oh that doesn't oh
it's not a buffet if you have to ask the
guy to come over and then you order more
stuff yeah but then you go over to the
vegetable section and you get your own
vegetables that's not a buffet
that's a
yeah i'd say because buffet to me is
truly like everything is you can go up
and get it yeah yeah yeah so i feel like
when there's a block of you have to call
someone over and be like can i have more
meat that's how you get the fresh one
but you can also like go up to like the
chef at the buffet and be like can you
give me the fresher one depending at the
buffet i know las vegas yeah vegas you
can do it there's some really weird
buffets in japan though i went to one um
it's like an american chain or something
american chain here it's apparently
supposed to be an american dining chain
sizzler is that the way i know that's
isla sizzler in japan has like the
famous salad buffet yeah and it was the
most sizzlers in japan yeah there
and it was like the i think i went to
one in tokyo stadium or udabashi stadium
the one that ibashi right
it's like a stage the massive stadium
the park tokyo dome tokyo dome that's it
yeah there's there was one in there
there was a sizzler or some form of
chain and i went
i didn't know it wasn't bubblegums i
went to it and i was like all right
what's going to be on the buffet it was
the weirdest selection of stuff you can
imagine right it was like the dessert
was like first in the buffet as well so
it was like ice cream
and like french toast but this was like
5 p.m between first in the buffet like
like when you get your tray and stuff
the dessert was there first oh weird and
then i was like okay and then next to it
is like
self-service taco station
but there was no salsa or guac
so it was just like beef this is beef
wrapped up
yeah this makes sense next up it's like
pasta like italian pasta and it was like
i don't know what this pasta was it
didn't taste like anything it tastes
like a weird arabiata yeah it was really
strange and then in the middle there was
like a bunch of salad but the salad was
strange as well there was like barely
any lettuce there was like chopped
oranges
um like a bunch of croutons and stuff i
was like what is this in the hotel
oh yeah next to it oh the hotel buffet
no it wasn't a part of the hotel it was
like a but there was
yeah it was so confusing and it was just
the weirdest i've never seen a buffet
like it and half the stuff was terrible
and
they didn't have a coffee machine or
anything it was water oh it was just
water peasants instant sauce
and if you wanted the soft drink to
order it
that's actually normal in a lot of
buffets
in england as well because that's how
they make the money because that's you
have to pay for this we pay for the
drinks in the uk some buffet places a
lot of buffet places the drinks i
thought they were alcoholic drinks oh no
they charge for like normal drinks as
well and that's that's how that's like
the secret of how they make the money
right because you have to order the
drinks separately but the food is like
all you can eat right right right so i
mean i mean that's that's more standards
how much are buffets in the uk oh we can
you can like depend if the tanner is
like standard you can go like pretty
high-end and get like 20 pounds 25.
really in the south it's like 20 to 30.
oh [ __ ] really yeah it's not it's like a
tanner
around where i was i think they were
like never more than twenty and twenty
was like premium like
produce seniors you can't you can't eat
out in the south like less than 15 quid
like 15 quids like the cheap because
you would go
you could go to any restaurant and get a
main for like 10 pounds like in like a
fresh maine that's prepared well so why
would you go to your buffet and stuff
yourself full of chips and rice
and pay 15 quid
fair enough
buffets are just fun for family i think
all the things yeah yeah because you can
challenge people you should get your kid
to shut up and run away challenge people
what do you what do you challenge people
like who may help who can
i did think it was really cool and there
was an all-you-can-eat buffet one time
and uh for pizza did you wear buffet
pants
what
it's like there's an eat buffet pizza
chain here in japan as well yeah called
shakies oh it's americans yeah that's
amazing
but wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait can we go can we go back to
the buffet pants what the [ __ ] is a
buffet pants i didn't even hear that
she said
she was like did you wear my favorite so
you can put the elastic band over your
stomach when you're done eating that
sounds like the most american inventor
like invention i've ever heard in my
in san francisco in my circle
we're like let's go to the buffet and
then we change our pants
we went to uh what
what
this sounds like a parody no are you
serious it's real
well in my friend group
did other friend groups do this as well
i don't know was this like a just your
friend group type of thing no it's like
more than
20 people how much does a buffet cost in
san francisco
an arm and a leg forty dollars forty
dollars that this was like eight years
ago though so it's only gotten on now
eight years ago well i mean yeah that's
how much vegas buffets are they're like
40 50 bucks oh they're worth it
i don't know
don't eat those they don't taste good
the high the high end ones though where
you pay a little extra like 80 90
dollars is like worth 80 90 dollars
what like that did you get like sirloin
steak on demand uh yes
you actually said
okay fine fine you actually get like top
tier food at those bar figures
yeah but i mean i mean 50 ones in my
opinion maybe about half the time not
worth it i mean i mean grand and then
spend 90 dollars on the state yeah
i mean that's just like sounds like
alien to me because like in the uk i
don't think that kind of buffet exists
buffets exist as like a cheap food a
cheap alternative to eating a lot of
food if you just want to order a lot of
food eat a [ __ ] ton of food they don't
really care about the quality but
they're a lot of indian
curry buffets because in sf certain
areas pretty much every buffet in the uk
is indian curry i'm gonna be honest
they're pretty bad though they're really
[ __ ] bad i mean i i would argue that
pretty like night actually i don't think
i've ever been to a good a good buffet
place in the uk in terms of like this is
good food you go there to eat a [ __ ] ton
of food and you trick your brain into
thinking it tastes good because you're
eating so much food right but in reality
it just tastes like [ __ ]
right i think that's most spot
i just hate like the whole plate
situation with buffets you know because
when you get a dish right that you've
hand selected it's normally perfectly
fit for that plate you know when you
start going around the buffet and you
start putting things on i don't want
some of the foods touching yeah
and like i hate that because i'm like
well you know i don't want um this saucy
dish to touch the thing that's supposed
to be like dry yeah so it's like it's
kind of a mess
but if there is sauce it's like all
right if this dish has a lot of sauce
how do i how do i kind of like integrate
this with my other food action on my
plate i've honestly never cared because
i'm like at the end of the day this is
all going to turn into [ __ ] so it
doesn't matter
oh so it's all going down
i agree
[Music]
[Music]
i'm like other buffet who has like
[ __ ] three different plates right
because you can't like
to like make sure the dishes are right
you don't get the food put it down eat
it and then go again no no no no no no
because that's too much effort what if
you change your mind though after you
eat the first place throw it away
it's all gonna get thrown out anyway
what if you take because sometimes i've
taken too much of something starchy and
i've been like [ __ ] i can't eat this
this is this is prime real estate in my
stomach i could have another bread roll
because in vegas i never get bread when
i'm in a buffer i'm kidding you
because in vegas apparently it's a law
now that all the buffet places at the
end of every day they have to throw out
like everything
because there was this lawsuit that dead
ass i read about this there was this
lawsuit that happened a couple of years
ago where they kept some of the food and
like stored it in like the behind like
the store
and some homeless guy came up ate it got
food poisoning sued the buffet place and
won
what well hopefully you got a nice home
yeah what yeah what and so now
yeah
and now in vegas i don't know about the
whole state of nevada but in vegas every
buffet place legally has to throw out
every single food that's left on that
day and make it fresh the next day so i
can't imagine how much that's good for
customers though but unfortunately
terrible for it's also a waste of a
shitload of food you'd wish they just
gave it away but it's logistically it's
quite hard to get away a lot of food
like donate it to the shelter yeah yeah
yeah
i think some coffee chains in the uk uh
especially london i think like prep does
it where like at the end of the day
someone will come in get all the
sandwiches they didn't sell and then
just at that night go and take them to
homeless people yeah yeah so that means
they're still like good to eat yeah that
makes more sense it's good yeah i am
curious as like the resident american
here oh yeah like oh i'm the only
american pretty much the only only
american in in the office yeah right
apart from sydney um but sydney doesn't
count
i mean she likes ugly bastard hentai
none of her opinions mean anything yeah
i'm like how do you feel when we
actually like rant about america and
you're just like off camera listening
that's true
confirmation
we have been wrong about something yeah
you have been wrong but i'm just hanging
out whatever
i mean yeah i mean we rag on about our
own countries just as much yeah and then
also americans will will like rag on
your country yeah of course yeah yeah
and whatnot we just it's interesting
though because like most of my foreign
friends are usually american
and it's interesting hearing
non-americans talk about americans
that i know has there ever been a time
though where you were just like no
that's so wrong and i want to tell them
there are a few times i just forgot i
mean the one that sticks out is the
butter or the lard thing
you were saying that there's some place
that they put lard on popcorn i was like
yeah i've never heard of that do we did
we ever find out where that was or is
that a lot i i don't know no idea it's
not a lie because i saw it with my own
eyes
so it's like it's not a lie maybe it was
that cinema i don't know but i saw it
maybe it's probably yes yeah it's
probably not like a common thing because
i was like
melted butter is definitely a common
thing yeah yeah yeah did you speak to
many non-americans who speak english
before like non-americans who speak
english
in japan
like koreans i guess so yeah
is there a big difference between
americans and
non-americans the way you guys talk some
things you say and then i end up saying
it
like what
i don't know like the time that i almost
convinced you that the australian
currency no i didn't believe you i was
just you know being polite to your
friends
so at smash uh which is the convention
in sydney the anime
uh yeah so i got invited as a guest and
meline came with me yeah and uh and my
my friend from uni was there i invited
them and uh and i don't know how we've
gone on to the conversation but my
friend dead ass almost convinced maylene
that the australian currency was called
dollar-y dues
before going i actually had an
australian friend here and she was like
oh
australians lie a lot so watch out
and then i went i think i told you i was
like my friend said australian smile
no no no no nonsense and then we told
you about the drop bears
i dropped there drop bears are like
there's a specific type of bear in
australia where uh
that they drop from the tree they drop
down and attack you so you should never
when you're in australia you should
never fall asleep under a tree because
drop bear could come down and uh attack
unfortunately that is a lie
i don't know it's absolutely real and
mainly believed me for a while yeah you
did you were like are they like an
actual species of bear
where where did the drop bear thing come
from oh [ __ ] it's been around since like
every every australian i swear i've met
abroad tells that story like on on my
first meeting i'm just like is this just
something the country has just agreed to
tell the entire rest of the world of
australians
every year prove that australia really
exists prove that it's not a lie
i haven't seen it yet i haven't seen it
i've not been to australia have you been
to australia yeah she's been have i yeah
she went on a flight and she landed
somewhere that was called australia but
that doesn't mean it exists you used to
be a big gamer back in the day right
meline used to play maple story yes
did you not talk to like
people on on maple story oh yeah from
all the countries my guild mother was
from australia oh did she lie a lot i
don't think so she told me about a lot
of things but like the drawbase what's
the guild
a guilt a person who starts the guild
would you would you put yourself [ __ ]
explaining
the master of the game
i've never heard of it referred to as a
guild mother yes it just happens like
you know online
people in the games they date each other
and you can get married in a maple store
you get crush rings or whatever
and
yeah yeah
so did you not have like questions about
australia for her
not so much i wasn't because i remember
the first time i made an american friend
i asked them about so much [ __ ] about it
about just like is it true that like
because you know in australia i did ask
a lot of questions yeah because you know
you hear from you only hear so much from
media right to the point where like a
lot of it is like over-glorified and
sometimes just like a straight-up lie so
like the first time i met my american
friend through youtube i just asked them
like a [ __ ] ton of questions being like
is this true is this i did ask my
brazilian friend about brazil though
by the maple story do they really have
big butts no i asked them because
there's just one case a rumor or
something that kids are very violent
when they get angry at each other in
games they like kill each other and one
of the cases that i was like checking
out was this 13 year old that like stole
a ps4 or something his friend and the
friend got angry went over his house
with the machete and just smacked like
cut him in half and i was like oh is
that true and then his my friend thiago
was like yeah yeah that happens all the
time so i'm not sure yeah yeah
i didn't he didn't say yeah yeah he was
like yeah that happens a lot in in
ventrilo ventrilo can can people confirm
that in the comments
brazilians is it true i don't know i was
like 13 14. does every brazilian kid
just own a machete
[Laughter]
but they're readily available so before
before before they learn how to read and
write they just get a machete
they come on amazon or something i don't
know i was 13 and they told me that and
i was like oh sometimes brazil's scary
i was always like the token british guy
and i went online to people from yeah
they were just like oh it's a brit oh
never met any british people in the
games really none maybe they played on
different servers maybe they did
yeah like how much growing up did you
know about the rest of the world because
like the stereotype is that americans
are nothing no nothing about the rest of
the world that's like the stereotype i'm
not saying it's true but you know about
europeans or australians or south africa
you're vietnamese right yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah
i mean i got to travel to a lot of parts
of asia
i know about asia i mean i i don't know
much about asia i just i know the names
of the countries and some of the history
and here you are in japan
and now you're learning you're educating
yourself
about things i knew about the history
but that's about it
he knew the history
we colonized this place
just look at the list it's like yeah is
that part of my class it sounds really
because often you would hear about
countries and it was always like it was
like 50 50 i'm like did we
no
we got close
maybe we just stopped right there yeah
asian issue is really cool when you
learn about it but i was just saying you
never got taught in school in the uk
because they were like that's that far
away place that you'll never go because
europe and butlins is an hour away so
yeah but at least you guys got to learn
about like european history right which
is like oh well [ __ ] that though
european history is such a [ __ ] mess
is it yes dude better than australian
history we only have 250 years and most
of it is racist yeah but at least you
can say like that's true but at least
i don't think europeans are any better
in terms of that literally white men
come to the person's land take land away
here we are today and then dump the
prisoners on
blah blah yeah and here we are like
[ __ ] 900 years arguing about who was
the best white person yeah but at least
you guys had like you know like wars and
like colonies
you're like cool [ __ ] yeah that's like
like the romans and like the byzantines
and like all those like that shit's cool
but like cool you know they make movies
out of them yeah
there's only one movie australian
russell
there's one movie about australia and
it's called australia
isn't it isn't it
you can learn all of your history within
like a reasonable amount of time yeah
but like as a 14 year old learning about
like politics and [ __ ] i'm just like
i don't i i don't know most of european
history i don't know history was like
that one
class that i just never paid attention
to it's true
i don't know about i don't know about it
like the most the most world history i
know is from the [ __ ] video from um
bill wurtz
that's that's basically what
after bill worth everyone is a [ __ ]
japanese store i was like hello i am now
historian
hello fellow historians world history
now
to be fair i learned a lot from those
videos yeah i did i did learn a lot from
it because i just never paid attention
in a history class yeah i don't know i
love him but i wish i could learn like
you know about like the japanese history
or you know like actually about like a
history of a country that is like you
know i actually i think japanese history
is interesting
i think i think chinese history is
interesting
i wish i learned about that stuff like
that yeah that's 4 000 years of history
that you can look back on right because
that's [ __ ] cool that's like so much
history and it's just like one place as
well as european it's just like is it
the romans this time like where is it
greece well europe had a war like every
[ __ ] fight i know right literally
like on the dot what percentage of like
the history of classes that you took or
have your question actually in high
school or middle school where it was
that
was dedicated to european history versus
i mean it was it was all european
history wasn't it wasn't what other
history did you learn american
i did not learn anything about me we
learned we learned american and chinese
history
how did they teach american history i
was mainly uh the civil uh the civil
rights period covered 50s space space
yeah the generic the space race the
highlights you know the highlights of
the modern american history that isn't
that they like to tell because it sounds
good it's like we beat racism let's end
it
beat the russians
you know like uh that kind of stuff yeah
i never learned about china was just
like um
i don't know i don't know which one is
the correct one because multiple
pronunciations of like mao
mao said there's mao zedong because
which pronunciation is correct because
we got we got taught a bunch of
different there's like 20 different
associations or something as well i
don't know which one's correct every
british person trying to like pronounce
chinese words yeah i'm terrible we
learned about that
see that's cool though because like we
had in australia at least in my school
we had ancient history which was like
about like the
we didn't do any ancient history
egyptians that kind of stuff that's
that's what we learned and then we had
modern history which was about like
world war one world war ii vietnam war
we did so much on world war two yeah
life feels like because british people
love world war ii yeah they [ __ ] love
course they do like like dudes like
literally like they're like they're like
look guys we we beat the odds
yeah cause like i i only remember world
war one and world war ii being taught in
my school it's like i think we were
taught a bit of american history but it
was just very glossed over
i don't know why so i don't know why it
was glossed over it was like for at
least for me i don't know if it was we
have gcses which are like when you get
to age 16 you can pick three or four
subjects yeah yeah yeah yeah one of them
was history i chose so that's that's
that's what you want history that's why
i did we learned american history and
chinese history oh okay because the most
i did the generic one was just like
world war ii yeah i did
up to gcse which i didn't even pick i
was just always like trench foot it's
bad
do you have accelerated like history
classes too like ap honestly no we don't
do that in the uk we have the only one
that has it is math we have advanced
mathematics right yeah yeah
we have that further maths
oh is it further further yeah
i know because i took it okay
that's the only subject
in the uk
trigonometry or something no
trigonometry was the basic stuff yeah
trigonometry you had to like pass
trigonometry
as to to get to further accelerated
maths was like you know like like
three-dimensional graphs and yeah
imagine imaginary numbers
and stuff like that but i i did notice
like when i compared what i learned to
school to what sydney learned at school
at the same time especially with maths i
don't know if it's just because i was
like i don't know if it was like the
education system but i would notice that
what i learned was like way before what
sydney learnt in school sometimes and i
don't i don't know if it's like i don't
know how the education system works but
then i also know that compared to asian
asian schools they are like way further
beyond what whatever i [ __ ] learned
in school like that was everything they
were doing like college level maths in
high school and i was just like what
yeah like in japanese schools you learn
long division at like fourth grade
and i'm like what i didn't win that [ __ ]
till i was like 16. [ __ ] is long
division long division is like divide
seventy two thousand four hundred and
sixty three by two hundred and seventy
three so [ __ ] though because you know we
everyone uses calculators nowadays you
don't need to [ __ ] know this [ __ ] did
you guys have like placement tests for
math yeah you did okay
how was it for you oh yeah we had
placement yeah and then oh man like how
did you place
i don't remember when it was are you
good at maths
i guess maybe yeah kind of
i suppose yeah what did you play what
was my test no how dare you
[Laughter]
wait what what subjects did you excel at
school
like what did you what did you take
what did i excel at at school
and stuff because they do like good you
can tell she grew up in an asian family
extracurricular activities right i
thought 4.0 was the highest it
is you can get higher if you do
extracurricular yeah every every single
true crime documentary is always like he
was a good kid he had a 4.0 gpa after
harvard yeah
absolutely cut off that woman's arms and
legs yeah pretty much
yeah i think the highest math i got to
is like algebra 2 because you can choose
to stop yeah right and i just chose to
stop and then fill it with other courses
so wait what was like your favorite
subject in school favorite subject yeah
art
maybe yeah i got to make like pasta
sculptures i got i i loved art because i
would ask myself well i could imagine
it's like [ __ ] macaroni art you
mentioned
something did you have like are schools
like well funded were your friends i
would say yeah well
area in the bears
is so bay
all the parents donate money oh oh okay
like someone i found like my one of my
aunts constantly donating money to her
daughter's school because it just
makes the program much better the
government's not giving enough money so
the neighborhood parents are just giving
money wow i remember when i did like
badminton there was only like two
rackets out of 30 that weren't broke
i mean that's that's just like school
equipment school facility but like like
like the the wiring is [ __ ] up yeah
that's the point where it's like you
just yeah play back yeah we had like 40
acoustic guitars and only two of them
worked oh my god this happens don't
[ __ ] get me started on textbooks like
when the [ __ ] teacher says all right
time to get out of the textbooks i'm
like who who who am i sharing with today
like are you everyone like huddles
around
right yeah because like like in my
school like
to like when when you were reading from
a textbook i you everyone needed to
share at least with one person so
everyone had a partner like a textbook
partner yeah yeah
yeah
but not by obligations because like half
the class had just forgotten their
textbooks so it just became like a
tradition to be like
it's my turn now do you have cooking
classes in america yeah we have cooking
classes it's like home egg or something
we're cooking class as well
i never took it because i hated oh we
had no choice oh really did you have to
cook in school nope they made this week
yeah we had to do it for one year yeah
oh they made us cook and they made us
you won't believe what one of the dishes
was we'd prepare a sandwich
that was no joke one of them
british cuisine be like
your bog standard lunchbox sandwich and
when i told my mum she had to buy me
ingredients to make it she was so
insulted that she complained to the
school
i mean i would be that's a waste of an
hour she was like i'm not buying
ingredients so he can make a [ __ ]
sandwich
right now how about i just make one
i made a quiche and i think it turned
out to be an omelette or something that
that's that's common yeah yeah like that
happened i was like i'm never cooking
again egg egg just anything that uses
egg turns into a different egg dish it's
just halfway through the process every
time i don't like that many egg dishes
this video is sponsored by manscaped
it's time to bundle up with the manscape
4.0 performance package inside this
package you'll find the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker ear and nose hair
trimmer crop ball preserver crop reviver
toner performance boxer briefs and a
travel bag to hold all your goodies
first off the new performance package
4.0 includes the new lawn mower 4.0 if
you're looking to cozy up this fall this
trimmer is essential their fourth
generation trimmer features a
cutting-edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
advanced skin care tm technology it also
gives you the ability to turn the 4000k
led spotlight on and off when needed for
more precise shave plus it's waterproof
the performance package 4.0 also
includes the weed whacker the nose and
ear hair trimmer use a 9 000 rpm motor
powered 360 degree rotary blade system
to provide proprietary skin safe tm
technology which helps prevent knicks
snags and tugs in those delicate places
manskip even threw in two gifts their
performance package 4.0 this time the
manscape tm boxes and the shed travel
bag get comfy on the home and on the go
this season it turns off plus free
shipping with the code trash taste at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code trash taste at
manscape.com choose manscaped and your
balls will thank you americans
americans
americans annoy me more than other
foreigners though i would say
that's on camera oh
why why do you why do americans annoy
you than any other foreigner
um very ex the okay the ones in japan at
least a lot of the ones that complain
about being in japan like i hate japan
oh they're so
racist or
no one wants to sit on sit next to me in
the bus
and they just had this horrible
experience in japan and they're mostly
i'm not saying
all english teachers are like this but a
lot of time they are english teachers
who are being they stay as english for
years and they dream of being in a
different position or different job yeah
yeah but there's just like all this i
hate japan america's the best but like
why don't you go back to america
but they don't and yeah so that's why
english teacher in japan seems like hell
did they complain more than us yeah
i don't know
wow wow different type of complaints
though okay and they're usually
generally very negative
when i complain i'd like to think you
know i very much understand where a lot
of them come from but off camera you
guys are always praising how amazing
japan is like oh don't don't tell them
that's our entire brand's mailing oh my
god
the absolute slander we're not going to
praise japan a lot of cameras not praise
but like you guys seem to be enjoying
we don't genuinely
i mean that's why we're here right yeah
just because we enjoy being here yeah
this positive energy
here in the uk what would i do in the uk
yeah oh hey guys gonna go to a bar
there's different countries gonna go to
a pub and uh
tomorrow i'm gonna go to another pub
yeah
you know for all the slander i've given
it if i did have to move anywhere i'd
probably go to america
really really probably living in a
country you weren't born and raised in
is fun it doesn't matter yeah yeah i
just want you to it's stimulating i'd
love to live in america for a short
period of time because i'd like to live
in europe really i don't live in europe
i'd like to live somewhere else in asia
probably just i don't know i just i just
really vibe with asian culture and asian
mentality that's that's not that we have
any plans for movies yeah yeah just just
hypothetically hypothetically if you
were like connor you have to get out of
japan you're being deported which
country do you want to move to i'll go
to america for a bit what do you
consider when you want to move to
another country is it like
the weather
i'll give a [ __ ] about the wildlife for
me it's about like whether i just vibe
with the way of living with the culture
as well like
as much as i like america i personally
don't think i could vibe with the
american way of life just personally
yeah what is the american way of life i
don't know it's just like it's just like
i cannot be a great american
[Music]
i think i'd be a [ __ ] i think you
would i don't know like i like going to
america i like american friends you know
i like you know being in america when i
visit but like yeah when i envision
myself living in america i just don't
see it
i don't know what it is it's just a vibe
like like as as as you like
you realize that sometimes you just like
subconsciously jive with some things and
like there's a difference going there
for holiday and actually living there
and i think we've all experienced this
in japan where coming here on holiday
visiting here and actually experiencing
and living the culture here is totally
different what do you do maitland
spilled some tea on the side and then i
forgot to swallow and then it was going
to spew out so it was having a crisis
no i think it would be some tissue it's
fine it was it landed on my shirt i
agree though i mean you know i find that
socially i
in america sometimes i'm just like
utterly confused yeah well i just don't
understand the person i'm talking to
yeah because i'll just say things and
i'm like why would you say that
in the uk though i don't really get that
yeah there's like a script almost
everyone follows yeah which is kind of
boring though at the same time but it's
coming it sounds like it gets monotonous
though right yeah you know when you go
to america it's always interesting like
you never have a dull moment it's i feel
like i'm very easy to approach and
you're also an extrovert right yeah i
guess so like for me whenever i go back
to america japan has like
made me more of an introvert so when i
go orders food and then the registered
person is like how are you doing oh like
trying small talk
and then i start sweating and then i
hate that but then you would love that
because you know you like the minimalism
because for me like that kind of
stranger friendliness that you get from
americans in america i've experienced
20 pluses of that in australia yeah so
it's like no different to me it's just
it's just oh you have a [ __ ] cause
it's so far from everything
i mean yeah also everything wants to
kill you but the food is so delicious
yeah you were frothing over there oh my
god
if you're saying the food's delicious
then have that good i gotta check this
out how many google reviews did you do
you can't like
we didn't have that much time yeah how
hard is it to get good internet in
australia it's i've gotten a lot better
in the past like since i've moved out
okay okay like if you go to like
melbourne or sydney like they actually
have
good internet speeds now finally after
all this time of course they had to do
it right when i [ __ ] left the country
honestly like i i think i could really
jive with the australian culture from
what i probably keep i just it's so far
from everything every everyone is at
least a 12-hour flight minimum from you
it is well like how how do you think
australians love traveling yeah yeah
yeah
exactly right australians like [ __ ]
everywhere especially in asia
yeah you're [ __ ] rid of them
everywhere san diego apparently huh
they're invading san diego apparently
really yeah why san diego i don't know
one of a few of my san diego friends are
like there's so many australians here
she says after meeting wanna start what
i mean
when i was growing up though i i always
thought america was way cooler than the
uk i just thought i think that's just
because you were born
to be fair growing up i thought pretty
much anywhere else was cooler than the
uk the uk right it's like you know
our image is on borrowed time yeah what
the uk actually is and what people think
the uk is is entirely different it's
starting to catch up with us now in our
lifetime if i've whilst when i was on
the when i was growing up everyone still
thought that brief people were like
charming and sexy yeah
everyone's like oh my god he's british
oh my gosh oh you know and then now it's
like tuesday bottle of water that's all
i get now and that's what i always
just get now we just get clowned on by
everyone including us because i'm just
like no no no we clown on ourselves she
can't clown on us you know the uk is uh
has very picturesque things his very
nice and elegant things but uh
unfortunately it's um
stones i mean the bricks
bricks bricks the buildings i love a lot
of materials oh like the stone buildings
yeah yeah
i love a lot about architecture
there we go
you know zooming in on the image of just
one of the bricks right like a stone
wall a single brick yeah and i was like
uk has nice bricks here it was nice it
was nice the uk was nice i feel like
it's kind of it's gone downhill a lot
yeah since the old the sheep running
through the fields the good old days no
not the days where i was born for me it
looked like it was pretty cool i don't
know if that's because i wasn't born
there yet but yeah
maybe i don't know i i feel like i feel
like some things were just cooler before
we were born i feel like you know the
stereotype about you know music was
better in my parents days or you know
when your parents said that i think
that's actually kind of true i think i
think i would love to have lived in my
parents age with some of the [ __ ]
bands and stars that they live at the
same time yeah but at the same time you
think about it it's like all right well
there's no internet uh there's no iphone
yeah or anything like that like
that sounds pretty crappy honestly when
you think about it like now that you
know the you know the whole
you literally handiness of today you
live you know you assimilate with
whatever you have at the time right you
get used to yeah yeah of course of
course even if you had no phone you'd
get it you enjoy other things yeah
whatever
but do you think like you know kids 30
40 years from now will be saying the
same thing about no
no i mean the uk the roaring 20s it's
very unfortunate because i feel like
they coming from like up north like
every or everything in the uk was kind
of like focused on london in the south
and there's the common sentiment from
where i grew up and around the areas
that like which kind of like abandoned
and all the money and stuff and all the
investment went to like london so a lot
of the a lot of the
northern cities in the uk are kind of
like been like deprived of any
economical advantages or anything and so
a lot of the cities are kind of getting
run down it's not very it's kind of like
japan isn't it yeah very much so but
unfortunately it's like i feel like at
least in the countryside of japan it's
like all right well at least they can
still do the local business of farming
and stuff in some certain uk towns just
nothing there's like nothing to do how
do you make money in those areas it's
all like it's all like minimum wage jobs
and there's no like big business there
or
you commute to the bigger city yeah yeah
yeah i mean i was thinking about this
earlier and i think we i i think as we
grow older we'll be able to say that we
did grow up in a pretty cool time
actually because we have like i was
thinking like what would be interesting
to like a younger generation to hear
about and i think the fact that we grew
up in the age where basically internet
was invented yeah i think that would be
cool that i think that'd be cool
generation of like people really who
grew up
initially without a smartphone yeah yeah
it wasn't like until like age
what like 13 i think yeah yeah
like imagine saying to your grandchild
you know let me let me tell you when the
internet just was assimilated into
society yeah i'm just like
i think that's a cool [ __ ] story
because like grew up in the [ __ ] vcr
dvd era right yeah yeah just like
ancient technology the kids today like
they're like wait what what the [ __ ]
like kids say i don't know what a vcr is
i'm like have i really gotten to that
point now where i'm just like oh you
[ __ ] youths of today don't even know
that what a bcr is you never had to like
stick the pencil in to like rewind the
tape and just let me let me tell you
about limewire and napster
let me tell you the war stories of how
we download how to download lincoln park
webster had to download linkin park and
got [ __ ] bill clinton for the 50
millionth time
question when when did you guys get your
first cell phones or smartphones i was
it was i entered high school high
school yeah i was 13 yeah my parents
didn't want me to get bullied they
really didn't want to get me a
smartphone but everyone else had a
smartphone
what was your first phone it was like it
was essentially a nokia brick yeah mine
wasn't an okay flip phone yeah i
couldn't even get a knock yet i always
got like a knock-off
he wasn't even this was at the time when
the sony like the walkman phone had come
out and so that was like the [ __ ] and it
was like the flip sony and that was like
the big boy now for us in australia was
the motorola eraser yeah there was like
oh
those ones all the cool kids had the
motorola arrangements
this is back when you you couldn't play
video on your phone so yeah yeah yeah
yeah so that was the phone i had and it
was just finished
especially for emergencies only but the
re we didn't text each other because it
was it was 10 pence to send a text yeah
that's right
yeah texting plans all you can do no
no they they didn't expect your friend
was like an urgent thing but at that
time as well when you had those phones
msn messenger yeah it was a thing as
well so you would never text because you
would just go you just go home and
message your name the only
was when like we said we're going to
meet at the place and i was there and i
couldn't find them and i was like where
are you because calling was too
expensive yeah because calling was like
10 20 pence a minute yeah exactly so if
if you press the call button you're just
like this is a [ __ ] emergency now
this is an investment
like my god
someone must be [ __ ] dying next to me
for you to be to be making a call man
what's going on i got the phone under
the condition of it's emergencies only
yeah
probably the same the same age i was
just curious like did you did you did
you go straight to iphone or did you get
like the flip no i had i not a flip
phone it was like non-flip phone and
then i got like the brakes right yeah i
think it was like a break like a little
antenna on top
because the old nokias had like a little
like knob at the top which was like the
antenna oh yeah that one that one yeah
were you a gamer growing up
wait yeah obviously she played
maplestory you're a gamer i played other
games in me what other games did you
play dory
but then you can level up your flying
abilities
yeah i do i own all of what's your
favorite console game console games
what's your favorite console
playstation
probably which one one two three four
well two i really like the lord of the
rings games king arthur
thank you games a lot of the rings games
on ps2 yeah they're very good yeah
they're pretty good played them in like
quite a bit quite a bit but you're more
of a anime person right obviously you
don't get an anime into this car
i'm sorry
i'm sorry you trying to bring uh gaming
into this
like the dichotomy of man so you're a
gamer well let me let me do the middle
ground then did you play any like anime
games
isn't maple story an anime game
that's what that's more like a game that
has anime aesthetic but it's not like
what is like visual
games right oh gosh i played hockey
shins like the dating simulations oh
yeah
yeah of course you did
that every every one she completed she
bought a new body and then
yeah because because i can see it yeah
because because i got it because i gotta
ask how did how the [ __ ] did the body
pillow addiction start how how did that
side of you start at all right
i don't know i like pillows i like
you come on i don't know i like pillows
there's a big difference in liking a
good pillow and a body pillow yeah okay
like i was obsessed with 2d i didn't
really like
people like male species just kidding
just kidding wow wow
sorry guys i just rich from you coming
i wasn't attracted to like uh real
people human
you went into 3d
yeah yeah you could just say that you
went into 3d like
and the way the 2d characters look were
just so pretty and i needed something
lifelike because what was the first like
anime or whatever that got you into the
2d world yeah
that made you give up on humanity
makes you reject humanity
yeah don't watch that clip yeah oh it's
just the exposure of their
chests
and yeah now you're like allergic to
nipple
because it's 3d points oh cause it's 3d
mark they always sense a nipple that's
right that's right yeah that's that's
that's why she can't see real nipple
because in anime yeah nipples just don't
exist for some reason yeah you're right
any of you guys come to my house or
maybe i'll bring a pillow or something
here um the naked ones yeah they don't
have the nipples
why is this did they do that on purpose
or is that how you learn i should
probably explain million is scared of
male nipples yeah yeah oh yeah where
male 1 is
male 1
apart from her husband melin is like
terrified of like male nipples no it's
because you know when you don't want to
stare at something but then you just end
up looking
and then
hold on
wait
feel like it's staring into my soul and
i just feel uncomfortable
oh sorry in other words in other words
you don't stare at the nipple the nipple
stares you back
yeah does your husband have nipples
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait no no
no
no
like my 2d i would have husband
boyfriend ex-boyfriend drinking
does your husband feel intimidated by
all of your body pillows no he says
something really weird wait never mind
we're good
you can go you can't you
we're just doing like the most normal
thing sometimes yeah
and i'm like that didn't come from you
can i tell them what he said about
drinking water that's like nah okay
oh when you see like anime characters
drinking water oh okay there's this
character i used to like are you talking
about the taste yeah yeah yeah no okay
so one like one of the characters i used
to like were still like oh my god i'm
tripping everywhere
when she talks about anime guys
his color's orange everything about him
is orange he smells orange and sometimes
you know
or if he's eating an orange
and you know you just want to know what
they're eating and
no yeah yeah yeah so she is does he
canonically smell like oranges no no no
she she said the weirdest thing to me
right because she was talking about her
obsession with uh 2d anime guys right
and she was just like did you ever like
did you ever see like a waifu or like
one of your waifus and you saw them
drinking something and you wanted to
drink the same thing and i was just like
uh no why did why did you want to do
that and i just thought i just thought
so you could taste what they're tasting
right and she goes to me uh yeah because
they just sometimes just want to know
what the inside of their mouth feels
like
[Laughter]
is that correct what you said sometimes
have like you know commercials in japan
where that character is endorsing this
and then you drink it too and then you
always think about them because they're
that's what they're drinking
does your husband feel like he's
competing sometimes no
no
well like i was also in long distance
with my
husband boyfriend at the time so like he
would drink coffee and then i'll be like
oh every time i drink coffee it's kind
of like
you're kissing
[Laughter]
it's not so much kissing as it's more
tasting the inside no no every time he
pees i pee it's like where it's like
it's like it's like we're crossing
streams yeah
yeah but like if someone's single and
they really like 2d characters
and you see your 2d character eating a
cake or something i definitely it's
called immersion yeah
who are watching this and they're
drinking coffee too it's the same oh no
never mind
he's always just like he's just like
yeah million is weird
that's what he says
what did he say to me sydney and sydney
told me
well monkey said oh i'm glad someone
understands or something
uh what
do you know my husband yeah of you yeah
like oh i'm glad oh yeah
i'm glad i found someone because uh both
our partners are crazy
were they were just sitting next to each
other i think you were in the corner
someone was having like a brochure yeah
i gotta come clean man yeah and they
started laughing out loud and i was like
wonder what they're doing because sydney
sydney and mainland hang out all the
time and sometimes it's just like it's
it's just like
two like it's just like the perfect
storm you know in the perfect song where
you have like two hurricanes and they
mix and then like they forms like once
one super massive hurricane that's just
whenever sydney they hang together
too much
just feed off each other's like chaotic
energy and they just like start saying
the most like cursed [ __ ] you'll ever
have to say something then
your husband would be like she's crazy
he just says that so that you think he's
normal too maybe maybe yeah that is true
yeah
is she still addicted to apex oh yes
did you ever say that no i haven't told
this oh yeah oh my gosh
i don't know we were at your we were at
maylene's house having a gathering yeah
it was like two it was after i think you
went home yeah oh yeah yeah yeah jojo
yeah so i think it was yeah actually on
my birthday yeah it was my birthday it
all goes back to
that because a lot of things happened
there so jerry had to go home early
because he had to film the next day yeah
um so we were at mayland um i guess just
chilling until like 2 4 a.m yeah um i
remember i remember at 2 a.m i'm just
like having a chat with maelyn um and
then i look over and [ __ ] connor is
like connor takes the controller off
maelyn's husband and it's like you need
to play this game he downloads downloads
apex
for maki and i'm just like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
how he plays every day i spent like
you've poisoned the world
i went to his house get the ps5 i
installed apex i was like which way now
we'll have so much fun he was showing me
these games on ps5 and i'm like this is
terrible these games are terrible let me
show you a real game it's free to
download let me download it right now i
downloaded it and then i i just thought
that maybe
he would play it a few times and then be
done but he's like addicted yeah he
plays every day every day
and i'll be in a call and he doesn't use
his like headphones so the walls
and i'm
and so this was awesome like to complete
the story we started like literally like
i think like a [ __ ] hour ago so we
start we start watching [ __ ] connor
teaching maki how to play apex right um
and then
it's this is like 3 4 a.m at this point
and we are obviously at this point
intoxicated now
you know when you're intoxicated maybe
sometimes you get cravings yeah you get
cravings mostly people crave maybe
pizza you know sometimes some people
pick crave a pizza obviously obviously
maybe people crave a uh kebab yeah you
know
a burger maybe a burger yeah yeah
go go to local chippy or something cool
get some get a chicken burger whatever
so melin is just sitting there and she's
just like
i feel like nigerian beef stew and i was
like
what
what what yeah
where did you get this craving from and
she was like i'm gonna i'm gonna cook
nigerian beef stew right now i was like
what who has this craving at three a.m
in the morning it sounds like a scripted
event i've
never heard of nigerian beef stew in my
life and here it is
for the first time
yeah sometimes maylene does talk like an
oblivion npc
what is an oblivion
npc
you sound like a video game npc you know
there's always so many things you're
like what is pog what is oh no i know
what i think
is right
i know you young people speak yeah
because like because like because like
the reason i bring this up is because
like she just had all the [ __ ]
ingredients for nigerian beef stew at
3am and i was like
the lights are only the disco lights
were on i'm very hungry i'll frankly eat
anything nigerian
disco
five dollar uh lightning funny image
it was it was so surreal just seeing
melody in the dark
and she's just like let me pull up my
spice rack
sleeping and i didn't want to wake them
up so i just you know having out all my
disco homies nigerian beasts
because you also grow um like carolina
reapers and stuff as well yeah ghost
peppers and uh yeah you gave them out to
people yeah and uh yeah they were they
were they were struggling
where did you learn how to cook or do
you just like follow youtube recipes
you're like i don't follow i just watch
a bunch of cooking things constantly do
you like july watch watch like what
gordon ramsay video
no
uh i i used to not anymore that was like
tv
jamie oliver
ramsey is more entertainment yeah yeah
yeah yeah educational but nowadays
there's uh so many different sources
on youtube and i just like food wishes
one thing i've noticed about a lot of
top chefs when they whenever they do
like cooking videos it's like it's they
always add so much [ __ ] olive oil i
don't know i don't know what it is about
[ __ ] olive oil you see a celebrity
chef at oliver and she's like just a
little touch of olive oil and they
[ __ ] invade italy in the process i
swear to god man i love the uh
smash cuts
[Laughter]
so it's just just a little dollop of
olive oil
olive oil
it's like uh there's like a whole genre
of videos right is like uh absolutely
[ __ ] god-awful like cocktail recipes
yeah
not intentional and some of them are
literally just like full bottles of
alcohol like spirits is that the two
shots of vodka it's kind of like that
but taking it too far like i was
watching a video and it was this woman
telling you how to make a drink and
there was a cocktail yeah she put like
two leaves of coriander in a bunch of
shaved ice and then she's poured like a
whole bottle of like bacardi right into
this thing to fill it up and she's like
and there you go you have your and she
named the drink it's called and i was
just like what the [ __ ] is this
it's just straight bacardi this isn't a
drink it was like a pint glass as well
what the [ __ ] this is this is a hospital
uh booking correct
what is this
i want to show you some of these [ __ ]
cars
i didn't mix it with anything no there's
no mixer it's just it's just like some
some [ __ ] flowers and [ __ ] and a
whole bottle of jack daniels that's it
that's terrible essence of the stuff
it's still not a mixer
still not a mixer who's your favorite
youtuber mailing
do you even watch a lot of youtube i do
i watch a lot of food related youtube or
animal related do you watch report of
the week
[Music]
do sometimes like do you like his videos
like his videos
yeah
i don't watch it all the time it's like
once every two months i'm a big fan i
watch every video yeah you watch you
guys watch a lot though i mean i mean
we're like youtubers right that's that's
part of the job
are you a youtuber we are youtuber so
it's i mean it's just part of the job to
watch a lot of youtube and i i don't
know if that's just like warped my
experience because i don't know how much
youtube everyone else watches anymore i
do do you find that because like i
sometimes i talk to someone and i just
now i just assume they are also as verse
with like youtube culture and youtube
videos as i am i i always get reminded
that i'm way too deep into youtube and
memes when i have to when i say a meme
or a reference a meme that is so
in-depth in meme culture that it
requires like knowledge of like seven
previous memes yeah and then knowledge
of each like
variation of said meme yeah that's those
those memes are tough
because also some memes they are they
are funny if you get it but like when
you try and describe like pee pee poo
poo stinky yeah it's like there's no way
of describing that meme to someone
without showing the video without also
sound like a complete [ __ ] idiot yeah
like i'm glad you talked to me in like a
normal english level you know
what wait what do you mean
mom she'd be like what is buzzing i mean
i i have i have that reaction sometimes
of you
i just i i think boston is i i'm gonna
say i think button's an awful word
why wouldn't it feel like well because
you're not saying you're with class
you're comfortable with it you gotta be
you gotta be confident you gotta put
some bass behind it like bursting
[ __ ] out my cheek
tense up before i can even say it right
so wait who is your favorite youtuber
sorry oh jack japan would be like kim
marguerite cook oh i love him i just
love the way he cuts into the fish
kimono is this like he's pretty big he's
like top 10 japanese youtubers i think
but like he basically just dissects a
shitload of fish oh he that's the thing
this is the guy who killed the frog no
no no that's different that's like the
shock
the saddest thing is
that that frog there's a video on how to
prepare a frog and i think meline showed
me oh yeah they're just like [ __ ] i
think we were adding izakaya and i was
like no no because i i remember because
like this like sometimes because meleen
gets recommended so many food videos
sometimes sometimes you like the weird
cooking videos as well where you have to
like
[Music]
i feel like saying preparing the frog
doesn't do it justice it doesn't because
that's not what happened no the guy like
cuts this frog in half and you hear
bones crunching yeah he doesn't prepare
the frog he massacres yeah it's like
robot wolves but like
a man i feel like i just watched [ __ ]
saw seven yeah and i like just it's like
like we're not gonna put it up a screen
like if you're squeamish we're not gonna
talk about too much because it's i still
think about it and i'm not like i'm not
like a squeamish person but i felt so
bad for the frog
it's a [ __ ] brutal video that was
okay because you know he's going to eat
it yeah he wasn't doing it
of course not enough i recognize there's
nothing wrong with it he's going to eat
it he's not you know it's no more brutal
than killing a cow or something
educational right right i guess it's
just because you don't it's not every
day you see a guy chop a frog in half
yeah yeah to prepare some
you're enticing us you're in thailand or
vietnam because like you're never really
because the thing is you never really
think about how animals die before
before they cook they get good i mean
i mean we're so we we're so like we're
like lucky enough to like not have to do
it ourselves a lot of the times that's
what it's like to grow up in a civilized
society right so when i see a full-on
[ __ ]
yeah i mean i mean when i see a [ __ ]
mortal kombat fatality being put on this
frog i'm just like jesus [ __ ] grace
i'm just waiting for like the x-ray zoom
oh yes the hair's getting crushed
yeah yeah i mean obviously it's a brutal
video
pad is generally not that good yeah
that's why yeah that's why people turn
into vegetarians you know yeah yeah i
mean like i wouldn't i wouldn't eat
anything that i wasn't prepared to kill
myself yeah that doesn't mean i have to
enjoy the process
i feel like you're a psychopath if you
enjoy putting down an animal yeah yeah i
mean
i didn't know as in yeah
no i disagree i like the killing poem
i say if you don't enjoy it what's the
point it came out wrong
oh my god i don't kill i think just
bones crunching just is just generally
unpleasant because even when we were
when we had to like dissect fish or like
cut the bones just to separate parts of
the body it's it's often quite
yeah does it sound nice i don't enjoy it
i don't get much when it stops moving
it's like when it feels a little weird
right i think it feels weird yeah i
think it feels weird when it's still
moving yeah yeah that's that's how i was
waiting struggling yeah yeah don't say
struggle oh god god god
oh my god when i buy like live fish i
don't hold it down my husband holds it
down and i
cuz i can't handle what are you saying
he's like husband
you put the blood on your hands
he doesn't want to be the one to poop it
like you know
oh oh you're trying to hold it down
you're attacked so why can't you hold it
down because i can feel its muscles
moving like it's struggling
but you should be prepared for that if
you're going to kill it yeah if you're
the one like excitedly holding the heel
he's going to eat it too so it's we're
sharing the birthday oh wow so when i go
to the restaurant the chef's going to
come out be like i'm not going to like
i'm quite squeamish because you hold
down this this cow while i shoot it
you're just like blaming the you're just
blaming the murder on someone else yeah
you're just trying to pass
like we're in this together really
thinking like i don't want to go to hell
if
i get someone else to do it yeah it'll
be
i put the knife in this okay i put the
knife in there
okay
of course when we ask you for your
youtube recommendations you get to see
you being a brutal nurse no no i also i
also watch like food travel things like
best ever food review show oh yeah i
like that show yeah that guy's cool i've
been watching for like years yeah
because because like i'm i'm always
wondering why don't you make uh your own
youtube channel she does
i do yeah i've seen your videos
i mean
aside from aside from that one i i meant
like a because i've seen them i've seen
them as well four years ago
about which one the one with you like
reviewing like the man's body
you in the cosplay
no i was wearing cosplay it's just i
found this water bottle that was the
shape of a man's body and it was a high
q character and then i was seeing i saw
that it was trending on japanese twitter
that if you peel off the wrapping like
the clothes and then pour milk tea in
the full like the naked bonnie appears
so
i was so fascinated that i wanted to
show you you are literally the epitome
of the heavy breathing cat yeah
like whenever you see like a 2d male
[Music]
yeah no because like i i think it would
be because i i thought it's a really
interesting concept with you being such
a big google reviewer if you're just
like it's like the road to like the top
five percent or something like that
right well how long will it take maybe
yeah million has a twitter now so you
can follow on there yeah watch for
updates but i would love to see some
mailing gourmet
would you subscribe yeah of course of
course
i reckon you'd be really good at just
like food reviews because like i've i've
never seen i've never seen someone so
brutal brutal when it comes to reviewing
food
my god like you you have no chills yeah
whole review some of the stuff i've
heard you say is like it's straight to
the [ __ ] heart i'll be like this was
just the the most excellent meal i'm
extremely satisfied mainly what did you
think and then mainly it's like it
tastes like dirt because [ __ ] honestly i
don't want people to think anyone can
run a restaurant like in america a lot
of the times there's like these like you
have singles deterred me to everyone in
my own restaurant yeah okay you can't
you can't compare japanese restaurants
to american or european restaurants i'm
just saying people will move somewhere
or
and then they whatever country they're
from they think they they can make the
food of their country and represent the
country with that restaurant but it's
not that simple no of course not
actually i know they're trying to make a
living
interesting yeah but i don't know okay
so what are the things you look for when
you go to a restaurant like what's like
the number one thing of like everything
like the first thing depends what i'm
going for if i'm just going for like
thai or vietnamese food i don't i'm not
gonna look at how dirty it is how do you
how do you weigh each aspect so let's
say there's five stars does like the
food get three of the stars the service
gets one and then there's the you know
or is it kind of just like a package
it's a package it's like how i leave how
do i feel when i leave
or
yeah usually package deal yeah sometimes
i'll think of it like i already food is
amazing but the the weight it was rude
is that all right that'd be like oh my
god the food was so delicious but it's
just unfortunate that the service was
bad what one thing uh i was speaking to
chris about this and uh we were talking
about he was like oh you know i don't
wanna say anything bad about some stuff
because i don't wanna like you know
potentially risk them losing business or
yeah
and uh
you know
to me i said to chris i was like if a
place is so bad that you give it one
stars i genuinely
you know don't deserve they get to they
get to run a restaurant right give it to
the point where like it could be like
food safety yeah or it's just so bad in
every single way i don't care if someone
loses their job because they shouldn't
be in that job you just watch kitchen
nightmares yeah yeah just like you see
that you're like you don't deserve to
have this job
and they disrespect the
honestly like i sometimes i go to a
restaurant and i'm just like there's
nothing more disappointing than going to
a restaurant and just having
like a bad meal it's like so sad like
i'm i'm like my day is literally ruined
nothing is worse than a bad meal okay
yeah japan changed that for me because
in the uk it is it is like a 50-50 it is
it is whether or not the restaurant is
going to be
just good yeah most things are good but
they're not amazing because like because
like it's like it's one of the little
things in life to look forward to and i
look forward to just a good meal at
least once a day you know if i have like
a amazing lunch then dinner could be
like dinner could be a year but like i
just want i just want one good meal
whether it be home cooked or restaurant
or wherever it doesn't need to be ex can
be expensive cheap i just want a good
meal and if i'm wasting
my daily meal on a bad like on a bad
restaurant experience then my day is
literally like scam yeah i'm just like
you you took this from me you took my
you took the the only little joy my
money you took the little joy i look for
every day and you gave me an awful meal
and i'm just like yeah no that's just
that's just bad and like sometimes i
don't i literally don't understand
sometimes how some restaurants can serve
bad meals like like it it said to me
that someone went through the trouble of
opening up a restaurant yeah to serve
[ __ ]
seafood restaurants right now it's kind
of sad for hokkaido at least
they're not getting enough customers to
get like new batches of seafood coming
in so their ratings have dropped because
when the customers come in it's like
it's not fresh wow i can't believe this
has four stars i'm going to give it two
because it's really sad yeah because
because like the reason it blows my mind
is that how can how can just like myself
following a random youtube video i found
like i'm just following that recipe how
can that taste better than me being
served a restaurant meal that has been
cooked by a chef
right that i don't know
when you watch kitchen nightmares it all
makes sense you're just like these
people just want jobs they don't want to
cook they just want they want to work
yeah oh yeah i mean i mean you know at
that point it's just like it just it
it's just like why are you in the
restaurant business
because it's not easy to run a [ __ ]
restaurant like it's not you don't have
to run a restaurant to know that that's
[ __ ] hard work yeah so it's like why
would you spend all that time money and
effort to then just get a bunch of
people come into your restaurant hate
your food hate your service and then
leave disappointed so what's the point i
think i would rather
my local restaurant to have more passion
than whoever's doing surgery on me i
don't think i don't really need my
surgeon to be passionate about it i need
my restaurant tour to be passionate
about what they're doing yeah because
you know
you know who cares about doing open
heart surgery i don't care about that he
probably doesn't care about that i'll be
the person getting like yeah yeah
but that probably doesn't mean [ __ ] if
then you you get the surgery you live
and then you go to a [ __ ] restaurant
afterwards what's the point so to me
it's way more important that there are
some jobs that need passion and
you say that as if you have open heart
surgery as often as you have a meal
you know there's a bit of a different
story even even then i would still
rather you know
even be dis-passionate about it there
are some jobs where i'm like you don't
need to be passionate about this job
mm-hmm
restaurant is one of those jobs no no no
no definitely restaurant like some
sometimes it just you can just feel the
passion coming out of like the meal
right yeah and the people running again
those are the best meals
you like it when the chef comes out and
asks you like how did you lose you like
it i love that that shows to me
she cares yeah yeah yeah because this
isn't just me he's probably doing it too
yeah obviously
obviously he's doing that to like
everyone yeah yeah
because he cares yeah
that means a lot i like that or they'll
ask you which dish did you like which
one was a miss hit or missed yeah where
did we go recently where that happened i
know the italian place
what happened
where i got asked somewhere recently i
got asked oh it wasn't with you
it was with the uh
with us where we were sitting at the
counter it was the steak place we went
to the italian state place where
uh
that where we get the eight five oh yeah
yeah yeah
which place
the the one where we get the 45 or 48
day age steak
steak
we like we've been there we've all been
you've been there like three times i
think it's a counter seat they have an
open car we took chris there yeah oh oh
[Laughter]
that's on the lower end of age that i
have i i
only have the 90 days
you know i want to have steak five times
a week i typically go for the higher end
i'm sorry
i was good because i remember the first
i remember the first time we went there
and we were like they they gave us ask
every time yeah they gave us the menu
and we were just like uh can i get this
and this please and he's just like um i
mean you can but uh i wouldn't and i'm
just i mean
i i remember when when when when we
first went there we were like what a
rude [ __ ] brick telling us how to eat
our meal and then we got the meal and he
and we were just like oh
oh he he was right yeah he was
recommending us the good [ __ ]
but that i mean if if the guy is
confident enough she's like nah yeah
don't how often do you go to a
restaurant that happens never yeah
exactly right
like the absolute audacity but like
that's the thing that's such a big risk
because if that risk doesn't if if this
is like not one of the best meals i've
had yeah which it was by the way then
they're not then some serious balls but
normally in japan it's very common that
you will find restaurants that are like
max eight seating and there's only like
two staff yeah and normally you know to
to make pull off a restaurant like that
and and make it good requires a [ __ ] ton
of care yeah you can't run a two men
restaurant
and it not like and it'd not be totally
[ __ ] or amazing i feel like it's very
difficult i don't know
yeah i mean i didn't really appreciate
it until basically later in life because
i grew up with my parents running a
local family restaurant and i didn't
realize before because i i like to me
every restaurant was run like the
restaurant where i grew up in right and
that to me that was that was the bare
minimum that wasn't normal like i would
see my dad really taking care of the
customers and you know really talking to
them getting getting to know them and i
could see my mum in the kitchen as well
and i cared about her food so whenever
whenever she cooked something that
tasted off i was like mom this is awful
like why are you serving this to the
customers like like this this you can do
better mum and uh like i was i was like
the worst [ __ ] critic there and i
because it was my mom so i could i could
criticize my mom's cooking because i was
like i know huh did she cry no she
didn't cry
but
like i think gordon ramsay on it okay
you're [ __ ] what is this
she didn't cry but i'm pretty sure
whenever i'd say like whenever i'd say
she didn't cook a good meal like she
felt it in her soul and she's like oh
i'm gonna do better next time
all she
so that's why i like had a high standard
when going to restaurants so that's why
it blows my mind when i go to a
restaurant and i have like a bad
experience because i was like well i
thought this was just normal everywhere
you're running a restaurant you're
serving food yeah if you serve food
that's worse than what you serve at home
how is that how's that allowed how is
that illegal you could be the norm
though yeah how is that legal
paying for their skill yeah yeah yeah
you're paying you're paying someone to
do a service that you can't do so unless
you're a [ __ ] chef which most of us
aren't like [ __ ] michelin star chefs
i mean we don't have enough olive oil to
be mitch and star chefs most of the time
yeah you know you know so like you go to
somewhere else for them to cook the food
for you and if it's worse than what you
cook yourself then why am i paying you
for this meal yeah you know that's
that's just that's just my opinion it
was it was great you know growing up in
the uk uh up north you know the bar is
very low for culinary ability so
literally going outside of the uk is
like holy [ __ ] stuff tastes great mm-hmm
everything
there's not a best welsh
dish you don't have wash dishes oh we
have some we have uh welsh cakes
cakes what's a welsh cake it's like a
like a kind of like a i don't know how
to describe it it's like
a sponge cake or no no can you can you
pull it up
well it's like this weird like
raisin-esque like pastry
with some kind of uh icing on it i can't
remember i i never really liked it but
people loved it
and then like i had something called
which is like butter breathe yeah
there's para breeze which is like bread
butter breathe it's
what is what is this so that's the welsh
cake is this
raisin pancake um wait was it scones i
swear there's something else as well
sometimes you say scones not scones or
something or scones
[Music]
british people say scones do we say
scones
north or south i've always said scones
yeah i always say scones when
something on a hill that's apparently
the name of the welsh cake i don't know
something on a hill we had leek soup
that was a dish
what do you call
the meal that you have in the evening
tea
what what
[ __ ] northerners man
there's a specific australians that call
it that so i've had to adapt because i i
underst nobody understood what i was
saying because it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense okay pov you wake up
in north north uh you know
uk yeah uh you wake up you have
breakfast yeah right it hits 12 o'clock
you have dinner
yes yeah and then it gets to six pm you
have tea
not tea the drink tea the meal yeah i'll
ask my parents what's for tea and then
they'll tell me and it's even now yeah
it's beans on toast this is why
i've understood the tea equals dinner
thing i've never understood the dinner
equals lunch thing yeah that's the thing
that confuses me more like like because
the point is you have dinner in your
vocabulary and you just choose not to
put it for [ __ ] dinner it's like this
is like this is the one thing
northerners and southerners and england
can never [ __ ] agree on when you grow
up in the place in a certain place you
you rarely go to like south england if
you're from north england you're going
to go to north england if you're from
south south
there is there's a real like north south
divide travel a lot in the uk just out
of the uk yeah people always
it's like 90 percent actually it's it's
cheaper a lot of the time yeah it's
cheaper yeah because like trains in
england are so expensive
and like i remember like there was this
news article about how two students in
like two different universities wanted
like uh two friends from two different
universities wanted to meet each other
so they figured out that flying to [ __ ]
in spain was cheaper via easyjet was
cheaper than getting a train to like
meet each other so if you wanted to go
from uh
uh london to wales where i live it's uh
it's a three-hour journey and it's about
120 bucks
for a really [ __ ] train yeah it's not
it's not like a shinkansen where it's
nice yeah you feel comfortable there's
no outlets you're very lucky if you get
one yeah and uh that's like that some of
the trains are horrible as well yeah
basically like very expensive as a
student to like go anywhere you need to
book your train like three weeks in
advance get the [ __ ] advanced ticket
and you better hope that you get that
exact train yeah three weeks later so
you better and also like um you know
easyjet and ryanair would often have
deals where if you flew without any
luggage you printed off your boarding
ticket you could get tickets for like 15
to some european places
so it's like why the [ __ ] would you ever
like go up north or go down yeah yeah
exactly yeah that's true um so that's
yeah so you didn't really interact so
naturally i never really heard people
saying
uh lunch and dinner for
lunch and dinner but now i now now okay
now i say lunch and dinner because if i
say dinner and tea everyone thinks i'm a
[ __ ] weirdo so i have rightly so
rightly
that's right northerners i said it but
after like after like you know one or
two days of being back in wales i'll
start adapting back
assimilating back into the culture
become one of them
and i'll say
yeah so we say dinner for lunch and tea
for dinner yeah but it's weird because
you it's like do you want tea but it's
like a you understand you just know
depending on how it's been said or you
read the the time of the day if it's the
meal or the cup of tea yeah you just
know yeah yeah yeah
would you what if you asked for tea at
like seven you just know you just know
what's being asked
you would say can i have some tea or can
i have tea no but can i have some tea
can also mean can i have some dinner
someone could be like i'm gonna make tea
that could mean a meal or that could
mean a couple sometimes people suggest
say copper i don't really like the word
cuppa
i don't say that in australia as well
i think i saw one of you tweet about it
i've never really grown in the wood
copper i don't know why it's not really
growing on me
because because some australians
especially those that have british
parents
they sometimes say tea for dinner even
in australia and that really yeah my
people like i i have a i i had a few
friends back in high school who had
british parents obviously from the north
and they yeah they used to say tea and
i'm like
i don't even drink tea bro coffee all
the way
and then when i realized yeah and then
when i realized they were talking about
like the meal tea i was like
what what like do you drink tea with
every meal like what does that mean
how british can you get my mom right she
microwaves bacon isn't that disgusting
oh i know a lot of americans that
microwave bacon
uh i mean i know a lot of americans use
the microwave for a lot of things
including water water
i thought i hated bacon but i realized i
just hated microwaves
yeah [ __ ] blame you because the fat
isn't crispy at all it's just
moist
sydney's dad microwaves eggs to make
scrambled eggs
that's like a walk that has to go
against the geneva convention or
something like that
that's a wall crying
i cook a steak in the microwave
nowadays though they're using air fryers
yeah yeah yeah yeah we get amelia
obviously
didn't you [ __ ] buy an ice cream
maker the other day don't [ __ ] tell
connoisseurs cream is the best dessert
i should bring the ice cream maker here
because i've locked it away because i
started
just like coffee flavored [ __ ] man yes
like not coffee jelly okay so here's
actually here's the thing i've noticed
actually so i do love coffee i'm very i
love coffee it's great i love my ground
water um but
i have noticed there's an awful lot of
influx of things that that have coffee
flavored things that are [ __ ] really
[ __ ] it's like
like where you get like coffee cookies
or coffee bread and it's just [ __ ]
terrible coffee flavor i've never seen
those i've never been yeah
yeah yeah i've had coffee cake coffee
cake tastes like [ __ ] i like coffee cake
coffee no just get a tiramisu i mean
that that is a coffee cake that's yeah
but that's not like breaded cake with
attitude i need to take you to this
place
where you it's a 90 dollar espresso
i had it three days ago ninety dollars
it was three yeah okay okay wait why was
it free my friend is a regular there so
oh well that's good for good for the
ones yeah
yeah
i'm not paying
quid for an espresso sorry we're not
well connected as like the [ __ ] top
five percent here
okay should i go with you i get it for
free why is it ninety dollars
absolutely
[Applause]
no you don't say anything if you're
regular you show up and then they
pass you the glass and it's the black
glass and then they're like so wait what
about it is 90 yeah what about his 90s
the way they roast it where the beans
are sore
isn't that like expensive coffee that's
made from like that cat poop it's uh
what poop you mean do you know the most
expensive coffee the most expensive
coffee in the world is made out of this
like wild cake it's like a weasel have
you not seen the bucket list no huh
oh copy lawyer yeah yeah it's malaysian
it's like it's like a big plot point
even in the bucket list it's like it's
like i haven't seen the button it's like
a beach it's like a malaysian like wild
cat species that eats coffee beans and
then they [ __ ] out the coffee beans
and then and the stomach acid creates
like this very special flavor of the
coffee beans people collect those beans
wipe off the poop and then grind it to
make coffee yeah apparently
it's actually really [ __ ] good is it
the best coffee in the world it's pretty
up there is it better than starbucks
obviously not
is it better than the nespresso oh
no
nespresso's in a league of its own
that's readily available
have you watched like those coffee
youtubers oh i can't handle it
it's like it's so [ __ ] pretentious i
i like to watch it like muted yeah
that's a peaceful one like i'm gonna
make my morning espresso and they bring
out like five [ __ ] contraptions and
it's like surely this is just not
practical like cleaning this is just a
nightmare sure yeah like
the reason why i don't grind my own
coffee beans and do all that is because
the absolute mess that it makes and it
takes so much time
like i i remember i like i got an
espresso machine before like nespresso
like it uh it actually was a proper
expression machine where you had to like
you know grind your beans yourself put
it in and it just it made so much
[ __ ] mess and it took so much time
like having to clean the [ __ ] beans
every time you want to just make a
[ __ ] cup of coffee like yeah i i
bought as well one of those like [ __ ]
uh pots that you put on the stove and
you put the espresso in the top and the
water in the bottom and it boils through
i couldn't have that at home i could
never get that to taste right i don't
know why it didn't taste good
because it was so hard to get the
balance right yeah and also cleaning it
was so [ __ ] difficult i felt like i
was trying to clean like iron man's
heart socket my hand couldn't fit in it
and it never got clean you had to resort
to just doing like yeah and it never got
it getting down
to clean the inside of a [ __ ]
pringles can it was a nightmare i
couldn't get in there and it was just
terrible and then it like it kept
scratching my stove because it was metal
and then and then it turns out when you
when you grind uh coffee beans they
expire yeah no one told me this until i
i didn't want i was wondering why my
coffee tastes like [ __ ]
yeah
this is this is a shower blend
i had like
some bite back to it i drank it for like
i [ __ ] you not like three weeks
like sour ass coffee because i was like
[ __ ] this gourmet stuff you drown it in
milk though [ __ ] no no i was thinking
especially this is the [ __ ] it's just
like like one of those like stomach acid
jesus sulfuric acid espresso but i
thought this is how the italians do it
[ __ ] did it affect your uh digest i felt
awful every time i did it but i i
thought this is a good espresso
expensive coffee beans on the back and
it expired like three months ago
literally drinking water acid yeah
oh
god glad you know gosh how it happened
there is so much food stuff there but
it's just a whole thing of
balance versus this is just impractical
it's making so much mess i need so much
equipment versus i just want to eat yeah
yeah you know yeah like sometimes if you
have time though
you're just doing it to relax like the
process
is like meditating i feel like it's a
hobby it has to be a hobbyist
[Laughter]
feel like you are
[Laughter]
that's a type of meditation where you do
something like you clean yeah then i
know that yeah yeah like like in uh when
i was a monk you had a special type of
meditation where you walk when you
meditate as well and it's just because
you uh you just drown out your
mental state with just a monotonous task
of emotion that's just constant right i
mean i get it but at the same time i'm
not always trying to [ __ ] meditate
when i cook you know like
coffee i don't know like to me when i do
something or when i make something i eat
like food or drink in order to consume
there's i always i always like i always
like compare the practicality and the
time it takes versus the time i enjoy
what i'm making right and that's always
the problem with cooking for me because
the time i take to prepare some certain
dishes and to make the food then eat it
which is a very very short amount of
time compared to preparing it and then i
gotta wash it as well afterwards because
because you you eat it right and then
you're like you're relaxing you're like
oh this is nice [ __ ] i gotta clean all
this stuff yeah god damn i used the ice
cream machine it's got like four [ __ ]
spatulas
ice cream machine is very easy you just
rinse it with water and it smells
so good you're just you're just bribing
him now it's so good you will know next
week yeah next week bring it and we'll
be on maybe maybe we'll get a coffee
machine maybe one day i will you know
there have been times where i thought
about getting like a proper culture you
sure you just have
surely you just have to clean the the
metal scooper thing right that's it yeah
the metal scuba thing no well no because
you've got to clean the siphon as well
could it clean the siphon you want to
clean the milk uh you could just use the
nespresso thing though
for the milk or the milk problem
yeah props are pretty good what do you
mean
yeah i feel like milk frothing does not
need to be done by a thousand dollar
machine like i'm pretty sure i could do
with my finger if i did it fast enough i
mean like i don't need a machine to do
it i am the machine
pretty sure you get bored of that pretty
soon though
you know what is the worst [ __ ]
dessert
go on
the macaroons oh yeah no which kind of
all of them they never ever ever taste
as good as they love the sugary things
right the little strawberry
oh yeah i actually hate them
they're obsessed with them yeah they're
[ __ ] because they're kawaii af dude
it was a thing in la or sf too for a
while it just feels like sometimes
especially with dessert in japan if it
isn't instagram it's not like
instagramable it's not a dessert
macaroons for me are like feels like
that i eat two and i'm like done for the
year
it just tastes like [ __ ] you know what i
don't get
boba
that's that's that's like
i like boba what just why why why is it
so that's also like a twice a year thing
for me it's like like boba is just the
pumpkin spice latte of asia
i [ __ ] said it okay i [ __ ] said it
it is it's good it's good because it's
just milk tea it's just milk tea i get
it it's a chewy tapioca
sometimes you just want milk tea and
there's nothing like
why do you like why the [ __ ] do you like
bobby you know what they do you know
what tapioca is like it's [ __ ] jelly i
know
i don't know jelly i don't get i don't
get that it's just jelly you get the
tapioca it's just jelly
you're getting milk tea you're putting
jelly in it yeah i don't like tapioca i
don't have it but then
you don't like boba then you're like
drinking milk
literally you literally just milked it
participated i turned up to the the the
chain
because you bought milky from a boba
place it doesn't automatically make it
it's special
guys but also the second reason why i
love boba is because of the hilarious
[ __ ] videos we get out of the
absolute carnage it causes from people
choking on the [ __ ] tapioca to people
[ __ ] up stabbing it it's an endless
supply of hilarious videos it's like
nothing to do with it
nothing to do with the photos it is very
funny but it's got nothing to do with
you dreaming more about it but the part
the reason one of the reasons i love it
is just the endless entertainment value
and that when i love taking someone
who's never had boba to a boba place
because they always [ __ ] church who
hasn't had to okay who hasn't had boba
in this day and age
when wales no
watching people drink tapioca for the
first time and then just because you
could never ex you if you haven't drank
it
really yeah they struck you too hard to
just stop because
you've never drank anything that is like
that you don't want to drink balls that
big so
i can't cover everything
yeah so whenever you drink it right it
always catches you off guard the first
time yeah so it's very fun watching
someone go oh this looks good
even someone who's like experienced
drinking boba like knowing that it's
coming there's like a little like oh
the thing i don't get about um well what
can i call it boba culture because like
i guess there's a [ __ ] culture around
it now wrestling japan yeah because it's
like fellow boat drinkers because what i
don't get is that people go out of their
way to get boba and i'm just like it's
great why i have never understood it
especially in japan when like couple of
years ago when the burba craze was huge
yeah of just like these like high school
kids lining up for like two hours oh
yeah
yeah like
what's it's literally milk tea like i
get some desserts i get some special ice
creams you know because because there's
there's only like ice cream huh
yeah honestly yeah yeah ice cream's a
great dessert i didn't say it wasn't a
great dessert i was defending jelly is
it the best dessert it's the way they
cook the tapioca pearls
the what is it the best dessert it is
the best dessert thank you carry on oh
my gosh
that doesn't mean that doesn't that
doesn't mean jelly is a bad dessert
jelly's still good yeah
they're so different though
boba jelly yeah the jelly texture is
entirely different it's way more chewy
it is i love the chewiness of it yeah
do you ever wedge them in between your
teeth i don't really eat it that much so
no okay
what
is that part of boba culture
what the [ __ ] you know what is that what
you have to do like assimilate into
public culture no is that what boba
drinkers do
you're just playing with textures with
the food i just i just wanted to know
what was it yeah no because like some
some some cuisines some desserts some
snacks i understand people going out of
their way to get this certain thing boba
it's just milk tea it's it's it's milk
tea with a bit of jelly in it and i just
i just i just don't in the mouth
with the chewing
you can do that with most foods mainly
is there a food that's like tapioca
that's same jelly mochi no no jelly is
soft mochi there there's more bites do
you like mochi actually
i i i i'm like on the fence about mochi
because i like the work
i like the way it tastes but then i also
feel like it should come with a health
warning because oh my god i like i'm a
normal functioning human being who can
who can who knows how to chew their food
and has no problem doing it and even i
feel like i'm going to [ __ ] choke
another mochi if i chew it wrong a lot
of old people actually die no i i i i
know i like mostly like rip it into bits
and then just eat the bits that you can
like yeah you have to take small bites
out you can't just throw the whole mochi
in your mouth yeah
like like mochi like [ __ ] mouth
breathers should not eat mochi like it's
it's like yo yo you're bringing this
back
you're playing with fire man
because their nose is congested
no if you're if you if your nose is
congested and you eat mochi that's
that's like that's like instant death
to death right there i'm pretty sure you
could just die anyway god how do mouth
breathers kiss them
[Music]
don't think they are incapable of
breathing through their nose i think
it's the default yeah that aren't their
nose
it's like people who have internet
explorers their default browser it
doesn't mean they can't use chrome it's
just that they don't all the time
they're just at a disadvantage they just
don't like it's just slow and you know
consequences happen
like i i like i didn't understand how
something could become like a choking
hazard like how food could become a
proper choking hazard until lego huh oh
yeah no no no no like like
like as an adult i'm talking like i i i
don't know
i understand as a child that a lot of
things can become joking houses but i
didn't understand it until i went to
america for the first time and i had
like my first american steak where they
it's it's like oh i know what you mean
and where they just like it's it's not a
steak it's just a slab of meat at that
point man they just they like plop it on
and you just like wow i kind of feel
like hannibal lecter right now man like
jesus christ and then you start chewing
into this thing and then you're like and
you start chewing it and it's like it's
just a lot of meat yeah i've never
this can be taken out of context i've
never had that much meat in my mouth at
once like just just in general right and
uh was it too much meat in your mouth
yeah it was a bit too much me in my
mouth
it was very hard to swallow and i'm just
like jesus okay i can understand how
people can choke on steaks now yeah like
but also if they use like a really cheap
cut of meat yeah holy [ __ ] it's like
chewing on leather it's like a dog toy
sometimes it's good though it's like
it's like beef flavored gum no what the
[ __ ] like that is the worst take i've
ever heard what the [ __ ] no when it's
chewy did you just say meat flavored gum
this is just chewing and the more you
chew but no more flavors will not break
down yeah no matter how much you chew
you cannot get it to separate beef
flavored gum holy [ __ ] what this is like
that scene in the 40 year old version
where like they're describing the the
feel of like breasts yeah just like yeah
it's like a bag of sand bag of sand
another one is too chewy that i can't
swallow it
i don't want to experience a meal
afterwards my jaw is just like ready to
fall off my face no no no no no no no no
no no no no i got you it's a meat
flavored tapioca
[Music]
there's a restaurant in japan uh and
it's like a chain called uh what is it
like inari
steaks yeah
[ __ ] abhorrent steak well so i went
there and uh yeah i went with a friend
and we're both ordering and i was you
know steak in japan is quite expensive
to get a good steak yeah and they bought
the cheapest steak but which also had
the option to have the biggest size out
of any of the steak so none of the other
steaks went over like 300 grams right
yeah for some reason this one steak that
was super cheap
or something it was like it was some
like it was called like but it was named
something like man meat or something it
was like
it was like something supposed to be
manly it wasn't it wasn't labeled
it wasn't no it was called monster meat
or something
that didn't even work
it was called like monster cut meat and
now i was like what the [ __ ] is that so
i was like you know what the sirloin you
get about half the meat it's about
double the price i'm sticking with the
sirloin yeah because yeah you want to
enjoy my meal yeah so so we're eating
and they're like the first piece they're
like [ __ ] this is
quite tough i'm hearing them chewing
chewing chewing chewing and i'm like
you're good and they're like
it's really hearty yeah they managed to
eat one bite and then i felt bad so i
was like yeah do you want to have like
we'll trade pieces like yeah so i gave
them two pieces of mine and i took two
pieces of that because i felt bad
because it was terrible yeah i'm nearly
[ __ ] choked on how bad this steak was
because it you literally couldn't break
it apart yeah you you literally can't
and and you like [ __ ]
and like it takes so much effort that
you have to start breathing through your
mouth
in order to like get the air and toilet
yeah
you know when you get to that point
where you're chewing me so much you're
like have i gotten this meat glob into a
size that i think is okay to swallow
yeah because i don't think i can break
it down yeah
yeah
that i won't show you and it's and it's
just like one is it soft enough that you
don't choke into sometimes you just cut
off like a bit too big of a piece it
doesn't break down enough and you just
have to like pray to god that your
esophagus can just like squeeze this
[ __ ] meat down
an absolute rookie era we took out take
out and we had plastic forks so there
was out there there was absolutely no
chance that because they'd already
pre-cut it into like pieces like this
yeah
which is like too too much yeah these
these pieces of meat from this this cow
that i assume was just benching all the
other cows i don't know what the [ __ ]
was going on with this cow to have meat
that was ripped that man
the fda was probably testing all the
[ __ ] drugs so he's doing some roids
or something it was insane how muscular
this cow was like good cuts there though
they did but yeah
like this the sirloin steak that was
like this big was like thirty dollars
yeah yeah it was terrible in which case
you're better off going to like a higher
end statement yeah yeah and the only
reason i went that's because everything
else was closed it was the only place
yeah they're open pretty late i mean
what did you expect from a place that's
literally called suddenly stage yeah
and then suddenly
it's kind of like japanese food in
the uk it's like
i'm not expecting much yeah and i didn't
go in there expecting a good steak it's
like the same i didn't expect good state
to be in japan because japan doesn't
really have japan imports most of their
normal stuff yeah in terms of like steak
steak like japan steak isn't great you
know they import nearly all of their
steak that isn't like the kobe yeah like
australia yeah trailer in america
uh yeah so
generally beefier is quite bad unless
it's like kobe beef but i get sick of
kobe beef i mean we've talked about this
previously you know you know what i miss
that i i found is like apparently only
in europe peppercorn sauce yes like i
like
it's
amazing steak sauce yeah it's like the
best steak sauce i've ever had i mean i
know peppercorns and you only get it
it's like it's like it's like a creamy
literal peppercorn sauce and i've i've i
thought it was like a universal thing
because
in england you have steak you have a
with peppercorn sauce
and it's just it tastes so [ __ ] good
and then i only realized moving out of
england even though other places in the
world have like better quality meats
like japan or america they have like
better quality meats than a lot of the
steaks you can find in the uk but it's
just where the [ __ ] are you going huh
where are you going i mean i'm in
brighton there's not there's not a great
steak in brighton honestly it's really
good stuff you're missing out god maybe
maybe but like the peppercorn sauce
would always save that steak for me
because like the the two of them just
tasted so good together and like it's
it's something you just don't find
elsewhere in the world apart from in
europe apparently that's the only place
i've found i swear i've seen it in some
restaurants in america i don't know
though maybe i haven't like
like your your steak is mid comment i
didn't properly get until i realized
that every steak here is with salt and
pepper and i'm just like okay now wasabi
which i just don't think is good on
stage
it depends it depends on the fatties
there's only so much
some of them have like garlic
actually it's it's different it's like
if it's yakiniku then yeah i'll have it
yeah
that's good
that's not usually that's not a steak
you know like
i have a steak in every steak here every
steak i've had in japan and most of the
places i've had i've been in america as
well you have the you have the option of
salt and pepper or in america you have
arjuna uh which is i think it's just
this liquid that comes out of the meat
yeah it's just the meat
it's just the meat juice meat sauce it's
literally the meat juices they pour it
back on
yeah okay and and i'm just like there's
there's so many different steak sources
out there like peppercorn and red wine
sauce as well which goes [ __ ] amazing
with steaks and no no nobody does it and
i'm just like why why i like i guess
steak tastes good but there's only so
many times i can have salt and pepper
and steak
uk steak with ketchup
yeah that's weird do they yeah
a1 i could understand it's kind of
ketchupy i like a1 we don't we didn't
have anyone in australia
what's what's wrong with you guys
why why'd you do that this this is why
everyone comes in everyone's like
everyone mocks me you know and british
people for growing up with this we don't
understand we're truly overpowered we
have literally no benchmark for food it
is so [ __ ] that when i go it's the wild
west
i literally go anywhere and i'm like
[ __ ] the shit's busting and it's got
like cockroaches in it and i'm like damn
this shit's so good
i i appreciate the boss and i i can i
think i can do you one worse because i
think uh
in thailand they eat
pizza with ketchup
what kind are you okay with that it's
tomato tomato puree tomato ketchup
it's just a not just a normal pizza like
a cheese pizza yeah
what other kind of pizza is whatever i
don't know i like pepperoni or [ __ ]
i'm going to be playing i'm going to be
honest if i'm at my house
i put tomato ketchup on the side and i
dunk the crusts in it yeah i do that
that makes sense that's good i do i do
the mayonnaise and ketchup combination i
don't need to do that
i don't i don't need to do that
brazilian barbecue i [ __ ] love
brazilian barbecue yeah
they're sauces that's what i finally
agreed oh my god
all of trash tastes agreeing on food
thank you
thank you brazil he made us agree on
telling her who knew that brazilians
could bring about world peace
i remember because i was in the first
time i had it was in japan because i had
a brazilian in my class
and they were like oh come to our
barbecue we're having one and apparently
there's a place in yokohama or no tokyo
bay uh where there's like fields where
you can rent like a tent spot right next
to the tokyo like water oh
and like a picnic spot yeah and they i
think they provide the barbecue you
bring your own meat yeah and they they
because uh she uh yeah she was a
food
scientist or something somebody like
designed food or something
something of that and then she was like
she's like you have to come come try and
i was like all right okay
yeah and they had like just amazing food
it was so good the sausage was amazing i
love sausage
is my favorite gastronomy right i don't
know that's the one something like
people would guess people would pay her
and she said that she would go to a
place like a chain or whatever and then
she would tell them how to make the food
better with science yeah or something
with science with science why didn't you
introduce me to her
mainly just like frothing at her
and like
every single item at this barbecue was
amazing yeah it was like everything was
like pre-season before it went on and i
was like i feel very happy you gotta
love the pre-season show yeah so i
turned up ate their food and then i was
like yeah i've got to go now
oh
but i actually had to go i couldn't stay
for long
yeah but as much as i could
i i remember like the
geeks plus opening party that we went to
which you unfortunately [ __ ] was not uh
because you were at the crunchyroll
awards i remember i remember the food
there was like so still i still remember
it to this day because it was like so
unique yeah it's innovative
yeah because they they booked out like
what was it like a two-star michelin
restaurant
actually invested into a michelin well
no they didn't invest in too much they
invested in an
innovative restaurant yeah got two stars
after like a year and a half of like
research and opening i had chipotle so
who's the girl
chipotle in my box of shorts no but that
restaurant is called inua and sadly
because of coronavirus it's closed
forever
they were very particular about the meat
they don't serve chicken beef or pork no
normal meat they don't serve the big
three
the big three
the rarest meat
it has to be
special here that's hunted in a specific
way and depending on where it's shot and
the side it falls it effect the blood
flow affects the meat okay now that just
seems a little tube that's a bit wanker
no no no no no it's not true what are
they gonna do where did you shoot it
where did you shoot it tell me
i can tell you in which way did the
blood flow did it flow uphill or did it
flow upstream or downstream was the wind
blowing i just shot it i just find it
hard to believe that that could really
affect it that much it does because like
the blood cells rupture and then it
contaminates the meat where you shop
the same with fish they're not clean
yeah same with the fish same as this
yeah fish fish is like one of the most
sensitive meats i think because you can
tell when you've had over the fish human
adult food
is it other than human no because like
you can tell when you've had like when
when you have fresh fish you know you
can you can tell when it's been in the
freezer like frozen fish is like instant
like uh like yeah you can immediately
tell you can immediately tell from like
the texture and the taste like if you
freeze like a piece of chicken well i'm
sad because japan ruined fish because
not now i can't eat frozen fish because
now i know what it is i never i never
could eat frozen yeah because that's all
you it's all we really ate
because you couldn't get that that's why
that's why i hated fish in the uk
it's always frozen yeah 90 of the time
it's frozen and i just i just think it
tastes real you can taste the frozenness
and that's just like the bland frozen
taste of fish that just every person the
uk has grown up with and that's why i
hated fish until i moved to japan right
because unless ninety percent of it is
fresh yeah yeah because unless you
actually went to a uk restaurant where i
actually shopped in a fish market
to get fresh fish and even then you
better go into the on the day that they
went to the fish market right yeah
that's why like you if if you go eat you
have to eat on like uh eat fish only on
like mondays basically because that's
that's that's when they mostly go shop
for the fresh fish from the fish market
and by friday it's all like old yeah
right
so yeah that i mean that sounds horrible
isn't your city though near the port huh
see that's a good question because you
know the uk is an island yeah we don't
eat [ __ ] fish
we card and we fry it that's about it
yeah it's kind of like why is it only
fried no you some people grill it
grilled fish isn't that common in the uk
i think i think fried is like fried fish
you can kind of hide the freshness right
a little more than if it was just like
maybe batter deep frying yeah the batter
hides the fact that it was probably
really because i think a lot of british
people did like fish i i mean i grew up
loving uh even like canned fish like
mackerel and
uh sardines sardines i loved i hated
that i love canned mackerel canned
mackerel is so good with baguette
oh yeah you can just spread it on like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i love it it's great you can just eat it
right out of the can you can put it on
stuff it's so good
that that is good
cause it's just like
it's so good as well because it's like
it's like one pound for like a can so
it's like oh like no no in the aldi was
like 60 pounds for a can and when i was
trying to lose weight that was great it
was just fish i thought it was uh
broccoli and chicken yeah yeah but
sometimes you had to mix it up for like
switch it up a little bit for lunch for
lunch i make sure i put like omelettes i
do like that yeah okay how long have we
been talking for feels like forever uh
we're recording 225.
what the [ __ ] what
what have we been talking about spoke
about food for like an hour and a half
[ __ ] my life
hope you guys enjoyed trash taste holy
[ __ ] sh i i i just i just feel like
we just we've been talking for an hour
what the [ __ ] is going on well thank you
so much
i guess we should probably
lean on twitter
[Applause]
or something along those lines i mean
you come up with so many shitty puns
when i'm with you and you refuse
yes yes what's the shitty pun
everything that's not gourmet
that's a great username okay i'll i'll
be calling
yeah you know what i haven't already you
know i can't i can't wait till we go to
our next anime convention and you
actually get recognized because you used
to be just the bookwork of run around
that just like i used to manage your
guys's lines yeah yeah used to manage
our lives
but now you're going to have now being
like are you gourmet
are you gourmet may from trash taste
maker of the boys i would start sweating
a lot
i'm sweating all the time
yeah i know i know
these patrons right here if you like to
support us though on patreon go to
patreon patreon.com trash taste also
follow us on twitter send us your memes
on the subreddit and if you hate our
face listen to us on spotify and also
let's go check out meleen well i think
they're going to be gone by the time
they're going to be long gone by the
time yeah yeah i hope you got your mugs
i hope you got your mugs because that's
to the fellow mug holders yeah if you
are watching this right now and you got
a mug pull them out right now this is
the moment you've been waiting for them
out whip them out
or whip them out take take a mug shot
shut the [ __ ] up
see you guys see ya bye
[Music]
you